Thank you for listening to the rest is history for weekly bonus episodes, add free listening, early access to series and membership of our much loved chat community. Go to the rest is history.com and join the club that is the rest is history.com Listeners to the rest is history will know that we do love a good sequel on the show. So 100 Years War, sequel. French Revolution, sequel. Captain Cook and Nelson haven't had the sequel yet, but I promise they're on their way. And I'll tell you what else is on its way. Our second Sunday Times bestselling book, The Restless History Returns, is out in paperback in May. And in in its pages what we do is to take you, the beloved reader, through an alphabetical miscellany of history's best and most bizarre moments from Cortez
感谢收听《历史余音》每周的独家加更节目，享受无广告收听、系列节目抢先听，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区。请访问 theresaishistory.com 并加入这个俱乐部，网址是 theresaishistory.com。《历史余音》的听众们都知道，我们节目非常喜欢精彩的续集。所以，百年战争，有续集。法国大革命，也有续集。库克船长和纳尔逊还没有续集，但我保证它们正在筹备中。我还要告诉你什么正在筹备中：我们的第二本《星期日泰晤士报》畅销书《历史余音归来》（The Rest is History Returns）将于五月推出平装版。在这本书的字里行间，我们将带你这位敬爱的读者，领略历史最佳且最离奇时刻的字母顺序杂锦，从科尔特斯
to Chaucer, from fashion to Freemasons, from Mitford's to monkeys. And on top of that, there's a pub quiz and there's a whole host of puzzles to test your historical mettle. So if you enjoy a sequel as much as we do, why not send your future self a little treat and pre-order your paperback of The Rest is History Returns now. Parents do not like the Rolling Stones. They do not want their sons to grow up like them. They do not want their daughters to marry them. Never have the middle class virtues of neatness, obedience and punctuality been so conspicuously lacking as they are in the Rolling Stones. The Rolling Stones are not the people you build empires with.
到乔叟，从时尚到共济会，从米特福德家族到猴子。不仅如此，书中还有一场酒吧问答，以及海量考验你历史造诣的谜题。因此，如果你和我们一样喜欢续集，为什么不给未来的自己一个小惊喜，现在就预订平装版的《历史余音归来》呢？父母们不喜欢滚石乐队。他们不希望自己的儿子长得像他们，也不希望女儿嫁给他们。整洁、服从和守时这些中产阶级美德，在滚石乐队身上从未如此显著地缺失过。滚石乐队绝不是那种能用来建立帝国的人。
They're not the people who always remember to wash their hands before lunch. Parents feel cheated. Just when the Beatles had taught them that pop music was respectable, just when they were beginning to understand what happens. Their children develop a passion beyond the comprehension of anybody for these five young men. So that was Maureen Cleave writing in the London Evening Standard on the 14th of April, 1964. Maureen Cleave, very groovy, kind of Anna Wintour haircut, probably the most influential pop writer of the day, first national newspaper journalist to champion the Beatles. She would go on to do the infamous interview with John Lennon in which he boasted that
他们不是那种总能在午饭前记得洗手的人。父母们觉得被背叛了。就在披头士乐队让他们确信流行音乐是体面的，就在他们刚开始明白是怎么回事的时候，他们的孩子们对这五个年轻人的热情，却超出了任何人的理解。以上是莫林·克利夫（Maureen Cleave）于1964年4月14日发表在《伦敦旗帜晚报》（London Evening Standard）上的文章。莫林·克利夫非常时髦，留着类似安娜·温图尔（Anna Wintour）的发型，可能是当时最具影响力的流行乐作家，也是第一位支持披头士乐队的国家级报纸记者。她后来对约翰·列农进行了那次声名狼藉的采访，列农在采访中吹嘘说
the Beatles were bigger than Jesus. But Dominic, we're not here to talk about the Beatles, are we? We are here to talk about the Rolling Stones. And what was the headline to that particular article that I just quoted? Because it's quite a good headline, isn't it? Yes. Hello everybody. The headline on that article was, But would you let your daughter marry one?
披头士比耶稣还要伟大。但是，多米尼克，我们今天不是来谈论披头士的，对吧？我们是来谈论滚石乐队的。我刚才引用的那篇文章的标题是什么？因为这是一个相当不错的标题，不是吗？是的。大家好。那篇文章的标题是：“你会让你的女儿嫁给这样的人吗？”
And that was inspired by an article that had run a few weeks earlier in Melody Maker. Would you let your sister go with a rolling stone? And I think that captures Tom, the stone's enduring image. So even today, I mean, they're in their eighties, aren't they? Mick Jagger and Keith Richards. I mean, amazing. Keith Richards is still around in his eighties. I know, amazing. But to people like our producer Theo, who loves the rolling stones, they're
这个灵感来自于几周前发表在《旋律制造者》（Melody Maker）上的一篇文章：“你会让你的妹妹跟滚石乐队的人交往吗？”汤姆，我认为这捕捉到了滚石乐队历久弥新的形象。所以即使在今天，我的意思是，他们都已经八十多岁了，不是吗？米克·杰格和基思·理查兹。我的意思是，太神奇了。基思·理查兹八十多岁了居然还在。我知道，太神奇了。但是对于像我们的制作人西奥这样热爱滚石乐队的人来说，他们
still symbols of kind of defiance of authority, of rebelliousness, sort of sexual excess. Everything that Theo embodies. Everything that we like our producers and the rest of this history to embody. Exactly. Now some people, I guess, may be thinking the Rolling Stones and a history podcast, really, but I think there are two dimensions in which they're really important. The first is obviously pop cultural.
依然是某种对权威的挑衅、叛逆以及某种程度上的过度放纵的象征。西奥身上体现的一切。也是我们希望我们的制作人和《历史余音归来》的幕后团队所体现的一切。没错。现在我想有些人可能会想，滚石乐队和一个历史播客，真的吗？但我认为他们真正在两个维度上非常重要。第一个维度显然是流行文化。
So I think it's the Stones, more than any other band since the 1960s, who came to define the look and the sound and the style of rock music. And I say rock music deliberately. Obviously, the Beatles are enormously influential in all kinds of different areas. But in terms of pure rock music, I think the look of the Stones in particular and their, as it were, dare I say their vibe, Tom? Tom McHenry The vibe, yeah. Tom McHenry The vibe. It's the Stones who established, as it were, the vibe. Tom McHenry You wouldn't say that from the kind of the 70s onwards though, basically they're
所以我想，正是滚石乐队，比20世纪60年代以来的任何其他乐队都更能定义摇滚乐的外表、声音和风格。而且我是特意说“摇滚乐”的。显然，披头士乐队在各种不同领域都具有巨大的影响力。但就纯粹的摇滚乐而言，我认为滚石乐队的外表，尤其是他们那种——怎么说呢——我敢说他们的氛围（vibe），汤姆？汤姆·麦克亨利 氛围，对。汤姆·麦克亨利 氛围。正是滚石乐队确立了这种氛围，可以说是确立了这种氛围。汤姆·麦克亨利 不过你不会这么说，从70年代开始，基本上他们
doing it as a kind of self-parody. Tom McHenry Yes, of course. Tom McHenry I mean, they're becoming completely predictable. They have a logo. Tom McHenry Yeah. Yeah. They became the first tribute act. Tom McHenry To themselves. Tom McHenry Yeah. in rock music history to themselves. But they're also, I mean, you mentioned the logo, they're huge commercial pioneers. And in the second episode, we'll talk about their later tours of the United States,
是在以一种自我讽刺的方式在做这件事。汤姆·麦克亨利 是的，当然。汤姆·麦克亨利 我的意思是，他们变得完全可以预测了。他们有一个标志。汤姆·麦克亨利 是的。是的。他们成了第一个致敬乐队。汤姆·麦克亨利 向他们自己致敬。汤姆·麦克亨利 是的。摇滚乐历史上向他们自己致敬的乐队。但他们同时也是——你提到了标志——他们是巨大的商业先驱。在第二集中，我们将讨论他们后来在美国的巡演，
where they charge higher ticket prices than anyone had ever charged. They recognize the business potential of this. I mean, of course, famously, they become tax exiles. Yeah, they go to the south of France, don't they? Exactly. So there's that. If you're interested in pop culture, the stones are obviously really important, but also in a more conventional historical dimension. The Rolling Stones become emblematic in Britain in particular of the 1960s. And I think their story, their rise and rise, normally we do Rise and Fall and
那里的门票价格比以往任何人定过的都要高。他们意识到了这其中的商业潜力。我的意思是，当然，众所周知，他们成了税务流亡者。是的，他们去了法国南部，对吧？没错。所以就是这样。如果你对流行文化感兴趣，滚石乐队显然非常重要，但从更传统的历史维度来看也是如此。滚石乐队在英国尤其成为了20世纪60年代的象征。我认为他们的故事，他们不断崛起的故事——通常我们播客做的是“兴衰史”，
History podcast, but this is Rise and Rise. Their story becomes a brilliant window, I think, into the world of 60s Britain. So we can explore all kinds of things like social class, economic and social change, attitudes towards drugs and whatnot. And we'll do this over two episodes. So in today's episode, we look at where they came from, what they represent, why they're so controversial, which I think is a really interesting question, and how they end up being cast as
但这是“持续崛起史”。我认为，他们的故事为了解60年代英国的世界提供了一个绝佳的窗口。因此我们可以探索各种各样的事情，比如社会阶层、经济和社会变革、对待毒品的态度等等。我们将在两集节目中完成这些。所以在今天的节目中，我们来看看他们从哪里来、他们代表了什么、为什么他们如此具有争议——我认为这是一个非常有趣的问题——以及他们最终是如何被塑造成
the sort of the yin to the Beatles yang. You know, that sort of Beatles versus Stones thing, which is obviously massively contrived, but which runs all the way through the 1960s and becomes a big cultural signifier, I would say. And today we'll be looking particularly at the man who founded the band, who I think is often a little bit forgotten today and that's Brian Jones. Originally it's not Mick Jagger's band, it's not Keith Richards' band, it's Brian Jones' band.
披头士乐队的“阳”所对应的“阴”。你知道，那种披头士对决滚石的戏码，这显然是人为精心策划的，但它贯穿了整个20世纪60年代，并成为了一个重要的文化符号，我想这么说。今天我们将特别关注乐队的创始人，我认为他现在往往有点被遗忘，那就是布莱恩·琼斯。最初这并不是米克·杰格的乐队，也不是基思·理查兹的乐队，这是布莱恩·琼斯的乐队。
So we'll talk about him. But first, Tom, would you like a little bit of historical context? I'd love a bit of historical context. Of course you would. You know, I love to embed popular music in historical context. Brilliant. I'm so pleased. This is why you're the perfect person to do this podcast.
所以我们要聊聊他。但首先，汤姆，你想了解一点历史背景吗？我很乐意了解一点历史背景。你当然想。你知道我喜欢把流行音乐嵌入到历史背景中。太棒了。我太高兴了。这就是为什么你是做这个播客的完美人选。
I know. I'm so excited. I do. Well, you know I do. You know that's why I love your books. That's not the only reason I love your books, but it's definitely one of them. So the Rolling Stones first become famous in 1964,
我知道。我太激动了。我是。好吧，你知道我是的。你知道这就是为什么我喜欢你的书。这并不是我喜欢你的书的唯一原因，但绝对是其中之一。所以滚石乐队在1964年首次成名，
and that's the end of 13 years of conservatism in Britain. The premierships of Winston Churchill, Sir Anthony Eden, Harold Macmillan, and finally, Alec Douglas-Hulme. Do you know Dominic, I hope that when this goes out as a video, maybe they could put in some video image of Alec Douglas-Hulme looking tweedy on a grouse estate, and then footage of the stones. Right. That's the classic kind of move, isn't it?
那正是英国13年保守主义统治的结束。温斯顿·丘吉尔、安东尼·艾登爵士、哈罗德·麦克米伦，以及最后的亚力克·道格拉斯-休姆的首相任期。你知道吗，多米尼克，我希望当这期节目作为视频发布时，也许他们可以在视频里放一些亚力克·道格拉斯-休姆在松鸡庄园穿着花呢衣服的影像，然后再切到滚石乐队的画面。对。这是一种经典的操作手法，不是吗？
It is. It's the juxtaposition. So in that period, the British Empire has largely disintegrated. Everyday life in Britain has been transformed by full employment, by massively rising wages, by free mass education. In other words, this is the absolute high point of what people call at the time the affluent society. And the people who benefit arguably more than anybody are young people.
是的。这就是并置手法。所以在那个时期，大英帝国已经在很大程度上解体了。充分就业、大幅上涨的工资以及免费的群众教育，彻底改变了英国的日常生活。换句话说，这就是人们当时所称的“丰裕社会”的绝对顶峰。而受益最多的人，可以说是年轻人。
So there are about five and a half million teenagers in Britain by the early 60s, and they are defined economically. In other words, they are an economic group really for the first time, who are spending more than 800 million pounds a year, and they are supporting a huge infrastructure of cinemas and dance halls and music magazines and record shops. And the magazines, the magazines are kind of driven by girls, right? And girls have a kind of outside influence on this teenage culture that's emerging. Yes, absolutely.
所以在60年代初，英国大约有五百五十万青少年，他们是由经济来定义的。换句话说，他们真正第一次成为了一个经济群体，每年花费超过8.f亿英镑，他们支撑起了庞大的电影院、舞厅、音乐杂志和唱片店的基础设施。而这些杂志，杂志主要是由女孩们推动的，对吧？女孩们对这种正在兴起的青少年文化有着一种外溢的影响力。是的，绝对如此。
Girls spend the most money. Girls are the most important. If you are a record promoter or you run a dance hall or you are a magazine editor, it's girls that you think about far more than boys. And it's girls who dominate, who are really important in the record market. So teenagers make up half the market for records and record players,
女孩花钱最多。女孩最重要。如果你是一个唱片推广人、经营舞厅或者你是杂志编辑，你所考虑的女孩远多于男孩。而且在唱片市场上占主导地位、真正重要的也是女孩。因此，青少年占了唱片和电唱机市场的一半，
and they buy singles, not albums. So in 1955, there had been 4 million singles sold. In 1963, 61 million. This is big, big money. And for the first time, I think you have a genuine national youth culture through television, so a really good example of that in August 1963, the BBC launched a program called Ready, Steady, Go, which is a kind of national pop program.
他们买的是单曲，而不是专辑。所以在1955年，售出了400万张单曲。1963年，达到了6100万张。这是一笔极其庞大的资金。而且我认为，通过电视，你第一次拥有了真正意义上的全国青年文化，1963年8月就是一个很好的例子，BBC推出了一档名为《准备、就绪、出发》（Ready, Steady, Go）的节目，这是一个全国性的流行音乐节目。
And it means that basically if you live in Scotland, if you live in Aberystwyth, if you live in Cornwall, wherever, you're watching the same thing, the same fashions, listen to the same music. It is a genuine nationwide phenomenon in a way that was unimaginable in the 1890s or something. And it's unimaginable now, I guess. Exactly. It is a much more national homogenous kind of story. Basically, to separate these young people from their money, record promoters on both sides of the Atlantic have come up with a succession of musical crazes. So the famous one in the mid fifties rock and roll, Bill Haley and his comets, Elvis Presley and so on.
这意味着基本上，无论你住在苏格兰、阿伯里斯特威斯、康沃尔还是任何地方，你都在看同样的东西、同样的时尚、听同样的音乐。这是一种真正的全国性现象，这种现象在1890年代左右是不可想象的。我想现在也是不可想象的。没错。这是一个更加全国化、同质化的故事。基本上，为了从这些年轻人身上榨取金钱，大西洋两岸的唱片推广人推出了一连串的音乐狂热。所以50年代中期著名的摇滚乐，比尔·海利和他的彗星乐队、埃尔维斯·普雷斯利等等。
But that doesn't last forever. By the turn of the sixties, that's over and record company executives are looking for something new and actually it's really funny if you look at the first years of the 60s, the mad things that they think might take over. So calypso or cha-cha or yodelling. Or kind of comedy songs, which a producer called George Martin is experimenting with. Right. Comedy songs done by people in bowler hats, you know, aca-bilk kind of thing, whatever.
但这并不会永远持续下去。到了60年代之交，这一切都结束了，唱片公司的高管们正在寻找新的东西，实际上如果你看看60年代的头几年，他们认为可能会接管流行乐坛的那些疯狂的东西，真的非常有趣。比如卡ypso（加勒比音乐）、恰恰舞或约德尔唱片。或者某种由名为乔治·马丁的制作人正在试验的喜剧歌曲。没错。由戴着圆顶硬礼帽的人演唱的喜剧歌曲，你知道的，阿卡-比尔克（Acker Bilk）那类风格，诸如此类。
Yeah. Digging holes in roads. Exactly. Window cleaners. And actually, as everybody listening to this podcast surely knows, even if they don't think they know it, they know that the big winners are actually the Beatles, Beat Music. And they rise incredibly quickly. So in October 1962, their first single, Love Me Do, didn't even get into the top 10. But a year on from that they Totally dominate the charts in a way that is unimaginable Really before or since I would say so nobody has ever had the hegemony
是的。在路上挖洞。没错。清洁工。事实上，正如每个听这个播客的人肯定都知道的那样——即使他们觉得自己不知道——他们也知道真正的大赢家其实是披头士乐队、节拍音乐（Beat Music）。他们的崛起速度快得惊人。所以在1962年10月，他们的第一支单曲《Love Me Do》甚至没有进入前十名。但从那以后的一年里，他们以一种前所未有、甚至可以说是后无来者的规模彻底统治了排行榜，我认为，从来没有人拥有过
Since that the Beatles had in 1963 64 maybe Taylor Swift is the only person who comes close But now the market is so fragmented. It's no comparison really. Now why this happens, I would say some people may disagree. This is not because of the Beatles unique genius. It is because the conditions have been established. So in 1963, the economy is roaring on all cylinders because Harold McMillan and his chancellor Reginald Mordling have unleashed a pre-election dash for growth. So there's tons of money around and more teenagers are spending more money on records than ever.
披头士在1963至1964年间所拥有的那种霸权，也许泰勒·斯威夫特是唯一一个接近这种地位的人。但现在市场太碎片化了，根本没有可比性。至于为什么会发生这种情况，我想有些人可能会不同意。这并不是因为披头士乐队独一无二的天赋。这是因为客观条件已经具备了。所以在1963年，由于哈罗德·麦克米伦和他的财政大臣雷吉纳德·莫德林（Reginald Maudling）发动了选前的经济冲刺，经济正全速运转。所以有大量的资金在流通，更多的青少年把钱花在唱片上，达到了空前的水平。
So in other words, if the Beatles had not existed, or if, you know, Brian Epstein hadn't discovered them or George Martin hadn't taken them over or whatever, I think it's reasonable to assume that some other band would have played that part because the market is sitting there waiting. Will you say band? Yeah. I mean, I'm not sure that part because the market is sitting there waiting. Well, you say band. Yeah. I mean, I'm not sure that's necessarily the case. It could have been a solo singer or something.
换句话说，如果披头士乐队没有存在过，或者如果布莱恩·埃普斯坦没有发现他们，或者乔治·马丁没有接手他们等等，我认为完全有理由假设会有另一支乐队扮演这个角色，因为市场正静静地等在那里。你会说“乐队”？是的。我的意思是，我不确定情况一定如此。那可能是一个独唱歌手什么的。
So, I mean, famously, Dick Rowe, according to Epstein, at any way, the Beatles manager says that guitar groups are on the way out, right? Yes. Guitar groups have finished. You know, and so that's why he doesn't sign the Beatles. And then a year later, it's Dick Rowe who signs the Rolling Stones on the recommendation of George Harrison, a member of the Beatles. And so the sense that it's the Beatles who blaze the path for the kind of guitar groups
所以，众所周知，据埃普斯坦说，迪克·罗（Dick Rowe），也就是披头士的经人说吉他乐队已经过时了，对吧？是的。吉他乐队已经完蛋了。你知道，这就是为什么他没有签下披头士。然后一年后，正是迪克·罗在披头士成员乔治·哈里森的推荐下签下了滚石乐队。所以人们有一种感觉，是披头士开辟了道路，才有了
that the Stones will be and the Who and the Kinks and everybody else. But it might not, you know, if it had been a solo singer, if it had been a Cliff Richard or somebody like that, then it would have gone on a different course. And it might not have been Britain. It might have been British. First of all, it almost was a solo singer. Frank Eyfield, who becomes the first person, I think, to sell a million records and has the first person of three number ones in a row. In other words, the potential for hegemony, for dominance of the charts, is greater in 1963 than at any point before. But I think the fact that it's groups that come through and the groups that then dominate for the next 10 years.
滚石乐队、谁人乐队（The Who）、奇想乐队（The Kinks）以及其他所有人那样的吉他乐队。但也许并非如此，你知道，如果它是一个独唱歌手，如果它是一个克里夫·理查德（Cliff Richard）或类似的人，那么历史就会走向不同的方向。而且它可能不一定是英国的。它可能一开始几乎就是一个独唱歌手。弗兰克·艾菲尔德（Frank Ifield），我认为他是第一个卖出数百万张唱片的人，也是第一个连续三首单曲获得第一名的人。换句话说，霸权的潜力、统治排行榜的潜力，在1963年比以往任何时候都要大。但我认为，最终突围的是乐队，并且这些乐队在接下来的10年里一直占据主导地位，
British groups. Suggests that there's something elated potential in the group because you can market four or five people more successfully and more appealingly to more people than you can market one. I would argue anyway, we could get massively bogged down in this. One other point about this. I think, I think it's really important to remember. Is very clear at this point that the appeal of pop music is not just and perhaps not even primarily about the music.
英国乐队。这表明乐队这种形式本身蕴含着某种巨大的潜力，因为与营销一个人相比，你可以更成功、更有吸引力地向更多人推广四到五个人。无论如何，这只是我的观点，我们可能会在这个问题上陷入无休止的争论。关于这一点，还有另外一点。我认为，我认为这一点非常重要。那就是在这个时候，流行音乐的吸引力显然不仅仅在于音乐，甚至可能主要都不在于音乐。
It is also i think especially about the attitude and about the atmosphere the critic mcdonald's wrote a brilliant book about the beatles is really good about this. The Beatles is really good about this, that it's actually about what we would now call, as it were, the vibe. Because a lot of people don't really listen to the lyrics, they're using the music only to dance to. Or famously just go and scream. Exactly right. And not hear any of the music at all. Now there are two other elements of this boom that I think are really important for the
我认为它同样——尤其是关于态度和氛围。评论家麦克唐纳（Mcdonald's）写过一本关于披头士的出色书籍，里面写得非常好。关于披头士的书写得非常好，指出这实际上关乎我们现在所说的“氛围”（vibe）。因为很多人并不真的听歌词，他们只是用音乐来跳舞。或者像俗话说的，只是去尖叫。完全正确。根本听不到任何音乐。现在，这场繁荣还有另外两个要素，我认为对于
Stone story. For the first time in the early 1960s, you have a cult of amateurishness. So in the 1950s, there was an expectation that a group or even a singer would have been picked and groomed and manicured by their management. And the songs would be written for them by professionals. But by 1963, there's an expectation that a young performer will write their own material it's meant to come from the heart. That does reflect the influence of the Beatles, doesn't it?
滚石的故事非常重要。在1960年代初的这段时间里，你第一次看到了业余主义的崇拜。所以在50年代，人们期望一个乐队甚至一个歌手是由其管理层精挑细选、精心包装和打磨出来的。而且歌曲也是由专业人士为他们创作的。但到了1963年，人们期望年轻的表演者自己创作素材，这些素材应该是发自内心的。这确实反映了披头士乐队的影响，不是吗？
Yeah. The Beatles are obviously really important in that. The Beatles are the heart. That does reflect the influence of the Beatles doesn't it? Yeah the Beatles are obviously really important in that. The Beatles are the model and secondly the other thing that is very unusual in 1963 is the overwhelmingly and unusually positive coverage of the Beatles. So rock and roll had always been treated with great anxiety. Famously the Daily Mail in 1956 had called it the Negro's Revenge African Tom Tom and Voodoo dance music. It called it even Cliff Richard. You mentioned Cliff Richard.
是的。披头士乐队在这方面显然非常重要。披头士乐队就是核心。这确实反映了披头士乐队的影响，不是吗？是的，披头士在这方面显然非常重要。披头士是榜样。其次，1963年另一个很不寻常的现象是，媒体对披头士乐队进行了压倒性且不同寻常的正面报道。因此，摇滚乐一直伴随着巨大的焦虑。众所周知，《每日邮报》在1956年曾将它称为“黑人的复仇”、“非洲鼓乐和巫毒舞曲”。它甚至称克里夫·理查德——你提到了克里夫·理查德。
So for non-British listeners, he's the kind of Christian mainstream, you know, the housewives favorite. He is now regarded by people in Britain as the sort of the acme of the sort of diluted, what would, how would you put it, Tom, the sort of safe, boring, bland. White bread. Yeah, white bread pop star. But at the time, the NME, the great kind of music Bible, condemned his indecent vulgarity, his violent hip swinging, hardly the performance any parent could wish her children to see. So this kind of sexual anxiety in particular is always there,
所以对于非英国听众来说，他是那种基督教主流，你知道的，家庭主妇的最爱。他现在被英国人视为那种被稀释的、怎么说呢，汤姆，那种安全、无聊、平庸的巅峰。白面包。是的，白面包流行歌星。但在当时，NME（伟大的音乐圣经）谴责他“不体面的庸俗”、“剧烈的扭臀动作”，这绝不是任何父母希望自己的孩子看到的表演。因此，这种对性的焦虑总是无处不在，
but not there with the Beatles. Brian Epstein has packaged them to appeal to the widest audience possible. So by the autumn of 63, when they're approaching their peak, the newspapers are constantly saying, isn't it amazing? We have this band and they're really funny and likable. And the evening standard, October 63, they've won over the class snob, the intellectual snob, the music snob, the grown ups and the evening standard October 63 they've won over the class snob the intellectual snob the music snob the grown-ups and the husbands i.e. the two groups you know who are least likely to approve of any pop musician that their daughters are listening to and then an
但在披头士身上却没有。布莱恩·埃普斯坦将他们包装得能够吸引最广泛的受众。所以在63年秋天，当他们接近鼎盛时期时，报纸不断地说：这难道不令人惊奇吗？我们有这样一支乐队，他们非常有趣且讨人喜欢。《旗帜晚报》（Evening Standard）在63年10月指出，他们已经赢得了阶级势利小人、知识分子势利小人、音乐势利小人、成年人以及丈夫们的喜爱，也就是最不容易赞成女儿们听的任何流行音乐的两个群体。然后在
amazing editorial i love this the daily mirror in November 1963 hair will be a big feature of today's episode by the way. The Mirror said, the fact is that beetle people are everywhere from whopping to Windsor, age 7 to 70. And it says it's plain to see why. The beetles are very cheerful, they're very high spirited. Quote, they wear their hair like a mop, but it's washed in capital letters. It's super clean.
一个惊人的社论中——我喜欢这个——《每日镜报》（Daily Mirror）在1963年11月指出：顺便说一句，发型将是今天节目的一个大亮点。《镜报》说，事实是，披头士迷无处不在，从沃平（Wapping）到温莎，年龄从7岁到70岁。文章说原因显而易见。披头士非常开朗，精神饱满。引述：“他们的头发像个拖把，但用大写字母来说，它是洗过的。超级干净。”
So is their fresh young act. They don't have to rely on off-colour jokes about homos for their fun. So what are they thinking of there? Exactly. This is the mystery. What are they thinking of there? I've often thought of like writing some essay about what lies behind that. It's a mystery. It is a great mystery. Let's get back to the Stones themselves. So we'll kick off with the real founder of the group. And this is a person who I think is a bit overlooked today. And this is Brian Jones. So Brian Jones is born into a very middle-class family in Cheltenham in 1942.
他们新鲜年轻的表演也是如此。他们不需要靠那些关于同性恋的低级笑话来博取欢乐。那么他们当时在想什么呢？没错。这就是个谜。他们当时在想什么呢？我经常想写一篇论文，探讨隐藏在那背后的东西。这真是一个谜。这确实是个谜。让我们回到滚石乐队本身。所以我们从乐队真正的创始人开始。这就是一个我认为在今天有点被忽视的人，他就是布莱恩·琼斯。布莱恩·琼斯1942年出生于切尔滕纳姆（Cheltenham）的一个中产阶级家庭。
His father works at the local aeronautical engineering factory. He's got a very suburban background, very respectable. He is, like so many people in the story of 60s music, very clever. He passed his 11 plus which for overseas listeners is the test that you have to do at the age of 11 to decide which kind of school you will go to in your teens. Will you go to a grammar school for the bright kids, aspirational kids, or will you go to a secondary modern where the government basically dump everybody else? He passes.
他的父亲在当地的航空工程工厂工作。他的背景非常市郊化，极其体面。和60年代音乐史上的许多人一样，他非常聪明。他通过了“11岁考试”（11 plus）——对于海外听众来说，这是你在11岁时必须参加的考试，用来决定你在十几岁时上哪种学校。你是去为聪明的、有向上流动志向的孩子们开设的文法学校（grammar school），还是去政府基本上把其他所有人都塞进去的现代中学（secondary modern）？他通过了。
He does very well at school. He passes lots of exams and does well. But he is badly behaved. He is, depending on your viewpoint, either extraordinarily reckless or extraordinarily selfish. In 1958, he gets a 14-year-old girl pregnant. In 1960, he gets a married woman from Guildford pregnant. In 1961, he gets another girl pregnant.
他在学校表现很好。他通过了许多考试并且成绩优异。但他行为不端。根据你的视角，他要么极其鲁莽，要么极其自私。1958年，他让一个14岁的女孩怀孕。1960年，他让吉尔福德（Guildford）的一个已婚妇女怀孕。1961年，他又让另一个女孩怀孕。
By the time he's 22 and the stones are becoming famous, he is already the father of five different children. The weird thing is, I mentioned Maureen Cleves and a Wintour Bob. He looks a bit like a kind of male Maureen Cleves a little bit. Well, that's his hair, isn't it? That's a strange sort of bowl haircut. Yeah, it's his hair. Cause there was a weird thing. So his girlfriend, Anita Pallenberg, didn't she say that he wanted to be Francoisardy or some kind of French Chanteuse and he would get her to kind of, you know, put on makeup and
当他22岁、滚石乐队开始成名时，他已经是五个不同孩子的父亲了。奇怪的是，我提到了莫林·克利夫和安娜·温图尔式的波波头（Bob）。他看起来有点像个男版的莫林·克利夫。好吧，那是他的发型，不是吗？那是一种奇怪的锅盖头。是的，是他的发型。因为当时有一件很奇怪的事。所以他的女朋友安妮塔·帕伦贝格（Anita Pallenberg），她难道没说过他想成为弗朗索瓦兹·阿尔迪（Françoise Hardy）或某种法国女歌手，他会让她——你知道的——化上妆然后
Well, in the next episode, we will discuss the Pallonberg Jones relationship, which I think the safe to say is tangled. Tom. Yeah. The theme of androgyny in the stones is obviously quite important. I mean, say with Mick Jagger as well. It is indeed. So initially he gets into Cheltenham art college, but then after news of his poor
好吧，在下一集中，我们将讨论帕伦贝格和琼斯的恋情，我认为可以肯定地说，这段关系非常纠葛，汤姆。是的。滚石乐队中的雌雄同体主题显然非常重要。我的意思是，米克·杰格也是如此。确实如此。所以最初他考入了切尔滕纳姆艺术学院，但后来当他不良品行的消息传出后，他被开除了，最终只能做一份又一份零工。因为布莱恩·琼斯，他将主导这两集节目，所以值得花一点时间来剖析他的性格。他是个非常聪明的男孩，敏感，非常需要别人的关注，而且非常、非常难相处。比尔·威曼（Bill Wyman）在他的书《唯一的滚石》（Stone Alone）中——这本书其实非常值得一读，真的是一本非常非常有趣的书——比尔·威曼说他是一只“昂首阔步的孔雀，合群、有艺术气息，拼命从同龄人那里寻求肯定”。
conduct emerges, he's kicked out and he ends up taking a succession of odd jobs. Because Brian Jones, he'll dominate these two episodes. It's worth pausing for a moment on his personality. He's a very bright boy, he's sensitive, he's very needy and he's very, very difficult. Bill Wyman and his book, Stone Alone, which is well worth reading actually. It's really, really interesting book. Bill Wyman said he was a preening peacock gregarious, artistic, desperately seeking assurance from his peers.
米克·杰格这样评价布莱恩·琼斯：我一直在练习。我真的做不到。这太难做到了。不，这是不可能的。他是一个极其难以相处的人。他身上有着非常非常受干扰的特质。他对生活很不满，极其沮丧，但他很有才华，不过他有着非常严重的偏执人格，不适合混迹演艺圈，基思·理查兹如是说。这是我能找到的最主要的评价。
Mick Jagger said of the Brian Jones, I've been practicing. I can't really do it. It's so hard to do. No, it's impossible. He was an extremely difficult person. There's something very, very disturbed about him. He was very unhappy with life, very frustrated, but he was talented, but he was very paranoid personality, not suited for show business, Keith Richards. This is the most principal thing I could find.
他以前的朋友和乐队队友。他是个混蛋。哈罗德·戈德弗雷（Harold Godfrey）说他是“不愿屈服的征服者”。是的。现在我认为关于布莱恩·琼斯的事实是，他显然是一个非常讨厌的人。他有着非常恶劣的一面。他跟约翰·列农有共同之处。他喜欢殴打女性。
His former friend and bandmate. He was a bastard. Harold Godfrey said unwilling the conqueror. Yeah. Now I think the thing about Brian Jones is clearly a very nasty man. He's got a very nasty streak. He has something in common with John Lennon. He enjoys beating up women.
他经常殴打女性。约翰·列农并不喜欢殴打女性，并且他为此感到后悔。但他确实殴打女性。他不止一次这样做。他确实这样做过，但是你知道的，他一生中最大的戏剧性在于他与那种本能的抗争。这种抗争。哦，真可怜。
He beats up women a lot. John Lennon did not enjoy beating up women and he repented it. But he does beat up women. He does it multiple times. He did, but you know, the great drama of his life is his struggle with that instinct. The struggle. Oh, poor him.
多大的受害者啊。多大的受害者。我们改天再聊聊约翰·列农吧。但愿不要。我们不要陷入关于约翰·列农的争论中。但愿不要。所以在切尔滕纳姆，有一个小型的波西米亚风格群体，就像60年代初英国的许多城镇一样。
What a victim. What a victim. We'll do a thing on John Lennon at some point. God forbid. Let's not get bogged down into an argument about John Lennon. God forbid. So in Cheltenham, there was a little Bohemian set as there is in so many towns in Britain in the early sixties.
艺术学院、咖啡馆，那些身为学生、参加核裁军运动（Campaign for Nuclear Disarmament）的人们。呢大衣。是的，还有那些有抱负的音乐家。他们会聚在一起，通常听爵士乐或民谣。而布莱恩·琼斯会吹单簧管，对吧？他在学校乐队里吹单簧管。所以是的，他带着他的单簧管准备好了。
Art college, coffee bars, people who are students, who are members of the campaign for nuclear disarmament. Dufflecoats. Yeah, who are aspiring musicians. They will meet up and they will listen generally to jazz music or to folk. And Brian Jones plays the clarinet, doesn't he? He played clarinet in the school orchestra. So yeah, he's ready with his clarinet.
哦，我想他还有一把萨克斯。他是个很有才华的音乐家。现在通过听爵士乐和民谣，人们开始接触布莱恩·琼斯式的蓝调音乐。所以对于那些对音乐不是很熟悉的人来说，蓝调音乐是19世纪末美国密西西比三角洲乡村的音乐，并在20世纪20年代左右传到了美国南部的城市，比如亚特兰大等等。然后通过20世纪40年代的大迁徙来到芝加哥，你就会看到像泥水客（Muddy Waters）和嚎叫的沃尔夫（Howlin' Wolf）这样的人。
Oh, and he's got a saxophone, I think. He's a talented musician. Now through listening to jazz and folk, people are starting to get into blues music. So blues music for people who are not massively familiar with music, the music of the rural Mississippi Delta in the late 19th century, and it spreads to the cities of the American South in the 1920s or so, Atlanta and so on. And then through the great migration to Chicago in the 1940s, you get people like Muddy Waters and Howlin' Wolf.
“Howlin' Wolf”怎么发音？Howlin' Wolf。Howlin'? Howlin' Wolf，这就是他的名字。这是故事中很重要的一部分，不是吗？如果你是个蓝调乐手，你就会把G音吞掉。没错。这就是芝加哥蓝调，这种风格在英国变得非常流行，使用的是电吉他。还有口琴。
How do you pronounce Howlin' Wolf? Howlin' Wolf. Howlin'? Howlin' Wolf, that's his name. That's an important part of the story, isn't it? You drop the G if you're a blues player. Exactly. And this is a sort of the Chicago blues, which is the kind that becomes very popular in Britain, is the electric guitar. There's a harmonica.
这是一种更具都市感的音效。在20世纪40年代末，美国杂志《公告牌》（Billboard）开始称其为“节奏布莱恩”（rhythm and blues），也就是R&B。这成为了一般黑人音乐的一个模糊委婉说法。显然，这种音乐对美国的埃尔维斯·普雷斯利等人产生了巨大影响，但它并没有进入美国白人的主流视野，因为唱片公司高管认为白人观众永远不会接受黑人音乐。换句话说，当像滚石乐队或动物乐队（The Animals）等人将其带到美国时，许多白人观众以前从未听过，这是他们成功的一个重要因素。
It's a kind of more urban sound. In the late 1940s, the American magazine Billboard started calling it rhythm and blues, as in R and B. And that became a sort of vague euphemism for black music generally. And obviously this music was very influential on people like Elvis Presley in the United States, but it doesn't go through into the white American mainstream because record company executives believe that white audiences will never take black music. So in other words, when people like the Stones take it to the United States or the Animals or whoever, a lot of white audiences have not heard it before, which is an important thing in their success.
但英国则不同。在英国，白人爵士和民谣爱好者并不像在美国那样受到种族禁忌的束缚。所以他们也开始听蓝调。这方面的一个好例子是当时最知名的爵士乐队领队，名叫克里斯·巴伯（Chris Barber）。他去了圣保罗学校（St. Paul's），汤姆。
But Britain is different. In Britain, white jazz and folk enthusiasts are not hidebound by the same racial inhibitions as in the United States. So they start listening to blues as well. And a good example of this is the best known jazz band leader of the day who's called Chris Barber. He went to St. Paul's, Tom.
这些人里有好多，是的。这些人里有好多都是文法学校男孩或公学男孩。这是一个非常奇怪且有趣的现象。克里斯·巴伯和他的巡演乐队演奏了大量的蓝调音乐。1961年10月，他们前往布莱恩·琼斯居住的切尔滕纳姆，在市政厅演出。19岁的琼斯去观看了演出，他完全被迷住了。演出结束后，他去了其中一家俱乐部——威基基俱乐部（Waikiki Club），去跟克里斯·巴伯的
So many of these people, yeah. So many of these people are the grammar school boys or public school boys. It's really strange and interesting phenomenon. Chris Barber played a lot of blues with his touring band. And in October, 1961, they go to Cheltenham where Brian Jones lives and they play at the town hall. And he's 19 years old Jones and he goes to see them and he is absolutely transfixed by it. And afterwards he goes to one of these clubs, the Waikiki Club, to talk to Chris Barber's
吉他手交谈，那个人叫亚历克西斯·科纳（Alexis Korner），他是英国小型蓝调界极具影响力的人物。是的，汤姆。你看，我得知这一点时大吃一惊，因为当我开始收听BBC第一台（Radio One）时，我所认识的亚历克西斯·科纳是一位DJ。没错。他的声音极其沙哑。是的。非常沙哑的声音。而且他做过一个关于吉他巨匠的精彩系列节目，那真是一种启蒙。是的。关于所有这些。所以发现他竟然和切尔滕纳姆的布莱恩·琼斯混在一起，谁能想到呢？所以布莱恩·琼斯为亚历克西斯·科纳弹奏了他的吉他
guitarist who's a man called Alexis Corner, who's a very influential person in the small British blues scene. Yes Tom. You see, I was amazed to learn this because I knew Alexis corner as a DJ when I first started listening to radio one. Right. He had an incredibly gravelly voice. Yeah. Very gravelly voice. And he did an amazing series on guitar greats, which was kind of an education. Yeah. In all that. And so to find him hanging out with Brian Jones in Cheltenham, who knew who knew? So Brian Jones plays his guitar for Alexis
科纳说：“我来展示一下我能做什么。”亚历克西斯·科纳说：“哦，太棒了。你知道的，你随时可以去伦敦跟我住。”所以让我们快进到1962年。哈罗德·麦克米伦担任首相的最后一个完整年份，即1962年3月。只是给大家提供一点政治背景。从未有过如此美好的日子，多米尼克。是的。1962年3月，亚历克西斯·科纳在伊灵
Cornish says, I'll show you what I can do. Alexis Cornish says, Oh, brilliant. You know, you can come to London anytime and stay with me. So let's move on a bit to 1962. Harold McMillan's last full year as Prime Minister in March 1962. Just giving people a bit of political context. Never had it so good, Dominic. Yeah. In March 1962, Alexis Cornish starts the first regular blues night at the Ealing
爵士俱乐部（Ealing Jazz Club）与他自己的乐队（名为Blues Incorporated）开始了第一场常规的蓝调之夜。其他俱乐部也开始效仿。它们位于伦敦市郊边缘的地方，比如吉尔福德、安多弗、里士满、特威克纳姆，都是一些相当富裕的小地方、被大伦敦无休止的城市蔓延所吞没的城镇。我想基本上发生的情况是，那些艺术学校里富有波西米亚气息的艺术青年——他们三四年前可能还在听爵士乐或民谣音乐——
Jazz Club with his own band, which is called Blues Incorporated. And other clubs start to copy that. They're in places that are sort of on the suburban fringe of London. So Guildford, Andover, Richmond, Twickenham, quite affluent little sort of places, towns that have been absorbed into the great sprawl of Greater London. And I think what's basically happening is that the art school, Bohemian arty people who would previously have listened to jazz or folk music
现在开始听蓝调了，其中至少有三位未来的滚石乐队成员，我们稍后会提到。实际上，蓝调和它的前身爵士乐究竟有何区别，在这些人当中引发了热烈的争论，甚至有过激烈的争吵，布莱恩·琼斯本人还在1962年10月给《爵士新闻》（Jazz News）写了一封信，阐述了他对两者区别的看法。他说，我认为这是一个相当不错的定义。他说：“爵士乐是理智的音乐，而蓝调只能是情感的。”是的，说得好。
three or four years earlier, they're now listening to blues and among them, at least three future Rolling Stones who we will come to. And actually what distinguishes blues from its predecessor, jazz is hotly debated by these people, there are furious arguments and Brian Jones himself writes a letter to jazz news in October, 1962 to explain what he thinks the difference is. And he says, I think it's actually a pretty good definition. He says, jazz is the music of the intellect, but blues can only be emotional. Yeah, that's good.
难道不是吗？其中有些更质朴的东西。这就是区别。他说爵士乐是理智的音乐，而蓝调只能是情感的。是的，说得好，不是吗？但其中有些更质朴的东西。这就是区别。我想这体现在氛围和声音上。而且他这时候穿着呢大衣吗？几乎可以肯定是的。他写的那封信充分说明了他的痴迷程度。比起任何一个未来的滚石乐队成员，他要更加痴迷于蓝调，程度要深得多。
Isn't that there's something earthier. That's the difference. He says jazz is the music of the intellect, but blues can only be emotional. Yeah, that's good, isn't it? But there's something earthier. That's the difference. It's in the kind of the atmosphere and the sound, I guess. And is he wearing a duffle coat at this point? Almost certainly he is. The fact that he writes that letter speaks volumes about his obsession. He is more into the blues than any future Rolling Stone will be by a huge degree.
所以到了这个时候，1962年春天，他已经在伦敦了。他做着窗帘推销员的工作。他有时会和亚历克西斯·科纳的乐队Blues Incorporated一起演出，但他迫切希望组建自己的蓝调乐队。因此在1962年5月2日，他在《爵士新闻》上登了一则分类广告。他说：“我想组建一支R&B乐队。
So by this point, spring 62, he's in London. He's working as a client salesman. He's sometimes playing with Alexis Corners Band, Blues Incorporated, but he's desperate to set up his own blues group. So on the 2nd of May, 1962, he puts a classified advert in the Jazz News. He says, I want to form an R&B band.
我是一名吉他手。我在寻找口琴手或萨克斯手。我在寻找钢琴手、贝斯手、鼓手等等等等。”他招募到的第一个人是一个叫伊恩·斯图尔特（Ian Stewart）的小伙子，他是一名苏格兰爵士钢琴家。他的下巴非常巨大，对吧？是的，确实很大，这其实毁了他的前途，我觉得可以这么说，就像哈布斯堡王朝的人一样。看起来像杂技演员丹（Desperate Dan）。然后在6份月，他又从Blues Incorporated的圈子里招募了另外三名成员。他们是来自肯特郡达特福德（Dartford）的两个少年朋友，他们就是米克·杰格、基思·理查兹
I'm a guitarist. I'm looking for harmonica or sax. I'm looking for piano, bass, drums, etc, etc. He gets the first recruit is a chap called Ian Stewart, who's a Scottish jazz pianist. Got an absolutely enormous jaw, hasn't he? He does, he does, which actually dooms him, I think it's fair to say, like a Habsburg. Looks like Desperate Dan. And then in June, he picks up three more recruits from the kind of Blues Incorporated milieu. And these are two teenage friends from Dartford in Kent and they are Mick Jagger, Keith Richards
和一个叫迪克·泰勒（Dick Taylor）的家伙。现在我们来谈谈米克·杰格。他是迈克尔·杰格（Michael Jagger），对吧？真的吗？他是迈克尔·杰格，但到这个时候他已经把名字改成了米克。杰格比布莱恩·琼斯小一岁，出生于1943年。他的父亲是一名体操运动员兼体育讲师。哦，就像捷克共和国那个阴险的家伙一样。
and a guy called Dick Taylor. So now we come to Mick Jagger. He's Michael Jagger, isn't he? Really? He's Michael Jagger, but he has by this point renamed himself Mick. Jagger was born a year later than Brian Jones. He's born in 1943. His father was a gymnast and a PE lecturer. Oh, like that sinister bloke in the Czech Republic.
我早就知道这个比喻要来了。是的，康拉德·亨莱恩（Konrad Henlein）。我的意思是，他们是截然不同的人。我只想把这个记录在案，以防米克在听。他的母亲是一名美发师，我读到过她还是一位非常热心的保守党积极分子。和布莱恩·琼斯一样，米克非常中产阶级。他在教堂唱诗班唱歌。他在学校表现很好。我认为这一点非常重要。他通过了“11岁考试”，进入了文法学校，然后继续表现优异，
I knew that comparison was coming. Yeah, Conrad Henlein. I mean, they're very different people. I just want to put that on record against Mick as listening. His mother was a hairdresser and a very keen conservative activist, I read. Mick like Brian Jones is very middle class. He sings in the church choir. He does very well at school. I think this is really important. He passes the 11 plus and goes to grammar school and then continues to do really well
并赢得了伦敦政治经济学院（LSE）的入学名额。人们往往会把这轻轻带过——这很惊人，不是吗？这是一个有趣的小细节。实际上，这不仅仅是一个有趣的小细节。这说明米克·杰格既非常聪明，又必定极其敬业和努力，因为要考入LSE——这是英国最具声望的高等学府之一，而在当时，十分之九的人根本连大学都不上，
and wins a place at the London School of Economics. And people often sort of pass that off. That's amazing, isn't it? That's an interesting little detail. Actually it's more than an interesting little detail. Actually, it's more than an interesting little detail. It says that Mick Jagger is both very bright and must be extremely dedicated and hardworking because to get into the LSE, which is one of those prestigious places in Britain at a time when nine out of 10 people
尤其是考虑到他出身的背景，对吧？肯特郡的达特福德。这是一个令人印象深刻的成就。他给人的感觉总是非常非常聪明。是的，他非常聪明。在这两集节目中，他都会显得非常聪明。现在，达特福德文法学校，他和水管工的儿子——一个能在文法学校上学、本身就很聪明的男孩，名叫迪克·泰勒——成了朋友。他们极其痴迷于爵士乐和蓝调，嚎叫的沃尔夫、泥水客、芝加哥的音乐，所有这些。他们在自己的卧室里组建了属于他们的青少年乐队。
don't even go to university at all. And especially where he's come from, right? Dartford and Kent. That's an impressive achievement. He always comes across as very, very smart. Yeah, he's very smart. He'll be very smart throughout these two episodes. Now, Dartford Grammar School, he'd become friends with a plumber's son, another very
正是在这个时候，迈克尔·杰格开始模仿这种口音。我的意思是，即使现在他的口音也是那么飘忽不定。是的。你知道，有时他说话很文雅，有时又带着那种奇怪的、紧绷的河口腔（estuary voice），而且他显然开始叫自己米克了，对吧？我的意思是，不叫迈克，因为河口腔他确实这么做了。而且他显然开始叫自己米克了，对吧？我的意思是，不叫迈克，因为他觉得米克很酷。好吧，他没说错。他真的没说错吗？我的意思是，在60年代初的达特福德的背景下。我觉得他应该叫自己米奇（Mickey）。
bright boy to be at Grammar School at all, called Dick Taylor. And they're massively into their jazz and their blues, the Howlin' Wolf, Muddy Waters, the Chicago stuff, all this. They form their own teenage band, basically playing in their bedroom. jazz and their blues, the Howlin' Wolf, Muddy Waters, the Chicago stuff, all this. They form their own teenage band basically playing in their bedroom. And it's at this point that Mike Jagger, he affects this accent. I mean, even now his accent is so variable. Yeah.
一个叫迪克·泰勒的聪明男孩，能去文法学校就读。他们非常喜欢爵士乐和布鲁斯，像嚎叫的狼、泥水沃特斯、芝加哥的音乐等等。他们组建了自己的少年乐队，基本上就是在卧室里演奏。爵士乐和布鲁斯，嚎叫的狼，泥水沃特斯，芝加哥的音乐，诸如此类。他们组建了自己的少年乐队，基本上就是在卧室里演奏。正是在这个时候，迈克·贾格尔开始模仿这种口音。我的意思是，即使到现在，他的口音也是那么变幻莫测。是的。
You know, sometimes it's quite, he's very well spoken and sometimes it's just the kind of the weird strangulated estuary voice that he does and he obviously starts calling himself Mick, doesn't he? I mean, not Mike, causeuary voice that he does. And he obviously starts calling himself Mick, doesn't he? I mean, not Mike, because he thinks Mick is cool. Well, he's not wrong. Is he not wrong really? I mean, in the context of the early sixties in Dartford. I think he should have called himself Mickey.
你知道，有时挺……他说话非常文雅，有时又带有那种奇怪的、紧绷的泰晤士河口腔音，而且他显然开始叫自己米克了，不是吗？我是说，不叫迈克，因为……他觉得米克很酷。嗯，他没说错。他真的没错吗？我是说，在六年代初的达特福德的背景下。我觉得他当时应该叫自己米奇。
Well, thank God you weren't the Rolling Stones producer. Yeah, right. Exactly. The Andrew Lou Goldham of podcasting. Yeah. So, very famously in October, 1961, Mick has, you know, calls himself is on his way to the LSE and he's standing at platform two and Dartford station when he notices a boy from primary school.
好吧，谢天谢地你没当滚石乐队的制作人。对啊，没错。简直就是。播客界的安德鲁·卢格·奥尔德姆。没错。所以，非常著名的是在1961年10月，米克，你知道的，自称在去伦敦政治经济学院的路上，他站在达特福德火车站的2号站台，这时他注意到一个小学时的男孩。
You know, who remembers from a long time ago. And this is Keith Richards. Keith Richards is from a much more working class family. His father worked in a light bulb factory. His mother worked in a baker's shop and he has grown up on a council estate. He is not a good boy. He did not go to grammar school, he played truant from school, he was expelled from Dartford Tech and he ends up at Sidcup Art College and he's also very into the blues. So they're standing there and Jagger notices him and comes over and sees that he's got these records that Keith is carrying these
你知道的，一个很久以前就认识的人。这就是基思·理查兹。基思·理查兹来自一个工人阶级色彩更浓厚的家庭。他的父亲在灯泡厂工作，母亲在面包店工作，他是在一个市政公屋小区长大的。他可不是个乖孩子。他没上过文法学校，经常逃学，被达特福德技术学校开除，最后去了锡卡普艺术学院，而且他非常迷恋布鲁斯音乐。所以他们站在那儿，贾格尔注意到了他，走过去看到基思正带着这些唱片。
records and we know this because Keith wrote a letter to his aunt Pat right afterwards and described I was holding one of Chuck Berry's records when a guy I knew at primary school came up to me. He's got every record Chuck Berry ever made and all his mates have too. They're all Rhythm and Blues fans etc etc. So they have this little chat and Mick says to Keith, Oh, do you know Dick Taylor? He does know Dick Taylor. What are the chances?
唱片，我们之所以知道这一点，是因为基思在那之后不久给他的姨妈帕特写了一封信，信中描述道：“当我正拿着一张查克·贝里的唱片时，一个我小学时认识的家伙走了过来。他拥有查克·贝里发行的每一张唱片，他的所有死党也都有。他们都是节奏布鲁斯迷，诸如此类。”于是他们聊了一会儿，米克对基思说：“哦，你认识迪克·泰勒吗？”他确实认识迪克·泰勒。这得有多巧啊？
Brilliant. Why don't you come and play with us? We can have our own little band and they set up their own little band called little boy blue and the blue boys. It's a terrible time. It is a terrible time. They wouldn't conquer the world with that. They would not.
太棒了。你为什么不来和我们一起玩呢？我们可以组建我们自己的小乐队。于是他们成立了自己的小乐队，名叫“蓝色男孩和蓝色小男孩”。这名字可真够逊的。这名字实在太逊了。他们绝对不可能靠这个征服世界。确实不可能。
Little boy blue. It's like potpast. It is potpast it is pop us So they're like playing in their bedroom and whatnot their mums kind of shaking their heads wearily and then in May 1962 They see Brian Jones is advert, you know, and they what are they now? 1819 and they answered the advert and the band is born. They played they met up They'd pay their first gig together at the marquee jazz club then in a basement in Oxford Street on the 12th of July, 1962. They decide to call themselves after a muddy water song and they call themselves the Rollin' Stones. Right. So no G, no G.
蓝色小男孩。听上去像通俗流行乐。就是通俗流行乐，没错，就是流行乐。所以他们就在卧室里排练什么的，他们的妈妈们则无奈地摇着头。接着在1962年5月，他们看到了布赖恩·琼斯的广告，你知道的，他们当时多大？18、19岁。他们回应了这则广告，乐队就这样诞生了。他们聚在一起，1962年7月12日，在牛津街地下室的马基爵士俱乐部一起完成了他们的第一场演出。他们决定用一首泥水佬的歌曲来命名自己，于是他们自称为“滚石”（Rollin' Stones）。没错。把“g”给去了，没有“g”。
And they are unambiguously basically a Chicago blues tribute band. So when they sort of announced themselves to the world, the jazz news asks them about their name and Mick Jagger says to jazz news, I hope people don't think we were a rock and roll outfits. Right. So it's only R and B, but I like it. Exactly. It's only R and B, but I like it. And you know what?
而且他们毫无疑问基本上就是一支芝加哥布鲁斯翻唱乐队。所以当他们向世界宣告自己的存在时，爵士乐新闻网向他们询问乐队的名字，米克·贾格尔对爵士乐新闻网说：“我希望人们不要以为我们是一支摇滚乐队。”没错。所以这只是节奏布鲁斯，但我喜欢。没错。这只是节奏布鲁斯，但我喜欢。而且你知道吗？
They're not very successful. No one likes them. They are too loud, they're too raucous, they're too sort of raw, they play in church halls and in sports clubs and nobody cares. So at the end of 1962 Dick Taylor goes off to art college. Jagger and Richards are basically, you know, they're like, well, this is quite good fun. We'll keep doing it. And they move in with Brian Jones in this flat in Chelsea. It's the coldest winter in modern British history.
他们并没有取得多大成功。没人喜欢他们。他们的声音太吵了，太喧闹了，太原始了，他们只能在教堂大厅和体育俱乐部演出，根本无人问津。所以在1962年底，迪克·泰勒去上了艺术学校。贾格尔和理查兹基本上就是觉得，嗯，这挺好玩的，我们继续干下去吧。然后他们和布赖恩·琼斯一起搬进了切尔西的一间公寓。那是现代英国历史上最冷的一个冬天。
The third coldest in all British history, the big freeze, all that water pipes freeze, they've got no money. Keith Richards' mom has to send them food parcels. And they are all very close to their moms, aren't they? They are very close. Yeah, absolutely. It's very sweet. So they're absolutely freezing and really miserable and nobody likes their music.
英国历史上第三冷的冬天，超级大严寒，所有的水管都冻住了，他们身无分文。基思·理查兹的妈妈不得不给他们寄食物包裹。他们和母亲的关系都非常亲密，对吧？他们真的很亲密。是的，绝对的。这非常温馨。所以他们冻得瑟瑟发抖，极其悲惨，而且没有人喜欢他们的音乐。
But somehow over the winter, they acquire two new members. One of them, they get a bassist. He's called Bill Wyman. He's also a grammar school boy, but he's a fair bit older. This is really important actually in the Stones internal dynamics. Bill Wyman was six years older. Well, he likes hanging out with people who are younger than him. He does indeed. He likes enjoys the company of young people.
但不知怎的，在这个冬天结束前，他们迎来了两位新成员。其中一位是他们找了一位贝斯手。他叫比尔·怀曼。他也是个文法学校的学生，但要年长不少。这在滚石乐队内部的权力动态中其实非常重要。比尔·怀曼比他们大六岁。好吧，他喜欢和比尔自己年轻的人混在一起。他确实如此。他很享受年轻人的陪伴。
I think that's a thing. He'd done his national service in Germany. So he's been in the army. He was married. He had a baby son and he has a steady job. He lives in Penj, but he's happy. He likes the music and he thinks, yeah, fair enough. Although that said, he is always more conservative than they are. He lives in Penj, but he's happy. He likes the music and he thinks, yeah, fair enough.
我想确实有这回事。他在德国服过国民兵役。所以他当过兵。他结过婚，还有一个小儿子，而且有一份稳定的工作。他住在彭奇，但他很开心。他喜欢这种音乐，心想，行吧，虽然话虽如此，但他总是比他们更加保守。他住在彭奇，但他很开心。他喜欢这种音乐，心想，行吧。
Although that said, he is always more conservative than they are. And he's always suspicious of what he sees as their bohemian arty side, which he doesn't trust. So he's the Dominic Sandbrook of the stones. Well, is he, or is the next person Charlie Watts? So Charlie Watts is a lorry driver's son. Yeah. Maybe you're more Charlie Watts. And also the Bill Wyman comparison is one I want to encourage.
尽管如此，他总是比他们更加保守。而且他总是对他们那种在他看来属于波西米亚式的艺术范儿保持警惕，他对此并不信任。所以他就是滚石乐队里的多米尼克·桑德布鲁克。好吧，他是吗？还是说下一个人查理·沃茨才是？查理·沃茨是一个卡车司机的儿子。是的。也许你更像是查理·沃茨。而且，将他与比尔·怀曼作对比也是我想鼓励的。
Charlie Watts is a lorry driver's son from Wembley. He's a trained graphic artist. His passion is jazz. He's a brilliant jazz drummer. He does not like rock and roll and he doesn't even like R&B. That's the amazing thing about Charlie Watts. I know. They have to persuade him to join the band and he only does it because he can see that blues is becoming more popular than
查理·沃茨是温布利一个卡车司机的儿子。他是一名受过专业训练的平面设计师。他的挚爱是爵士乐。他是一位出色的爵士鼓手。他不喜欢摇滚乐，甚至连节奏布鲁斯都不喜欢。这就是查理·沃茨最让人惊叹的地方。我知道。他们不得不说服他加入乐队，而他之所以答应，仅仅是因为他看出布鲁斯音乐正变得比
jazz and actually throughout the whole career of the Rolling Stones, Charlie Watts is basically playing music he doesn't really like. Just bonkers. And he's again, a very different character. He was married to his wife, Shirley for 57 years. He's not interested in the groupies. He doesn't go out going on tour. He collects model soldiers and memorabilia from the American
爵士乐更受欢迎。事实上，在滚石乐队整个职业生涯中，查理·沃茨基本上都在演奏他其实并不喜欢的音乐。简直疯了。而且他同样也是一个非常不同的人物。他和妻子雪莉结婚了57年。他对追星族毫无兴趣。他不喜欢去巡演。他收集模型士兵和美国
Civil War. And cricket memorabilia as well. Yeah, he's a great memorabilia man generally. He loves cricket, as actually Mick Jagger does. Mick Jagger's a big cricket fan, isn't he? And also Charlie Watts, very well dressed man, loves his tailoring. He is very well dressed. I think actually the Stones generally are very well dressed.
内战的纪念品。还有板球纪念品。对，他总体来说是个疯狂的纪念品收藏家。他热爱板球，其实米克·贾格尔也一样。米克·贾格尔是个狂热的板球迷，对吧？还有查理·沃茨，衣着非常讲究，对量身定制的服装情有独钟。他确实衣着极其考究。我觉得其实滚石乐队整体都穿得很讲究。
Yeah, they are. I think they're very well turned out. So 1963 comes and they get their big break on the 24th of February when Brian Jones, who's basically spends all his time writing to, you know, blues promoters and jazz people and stuff like this. He gets them a gig at the Station Hotel in Richmond, so near the railway station in Richmond. On Sunday nights, they have a club night called the Craw Daddy run by an emigre from Georgia in the Caucasus called Giorgio Gomelski.
是的，他们确实如此。我觉得他们总是打扮得光鲜亮丽。于是1963年来了，他们在2月24日迎来了他们的大好机会。当时布赖恩·琼斯把几乎所有时间都用来给布鲁斯推广人和爵士乐圈内人写信等等。他为他们在里士满的车站酒店争取到了一场演出，就在里士满火车站附近。每周日晚上，那里都有一个名为“爬行老爹”（Craw Daddy）的俱乐部之夜，由一位来自高加索地区格鲁吉亚的流亡者乔治·戈梅尔斯基经营。
The Stones come on and they play in this station hotel. And there's a rival promoter called Vic Jones who was there who said of that night, I honestly didn't know whether to laugh at the Stones or call for an animal trainer. I had never seen anything like them because they're just so sort of loud. That's a lot of shouting. Obviously Mick Jagger's style is very, he's kind of Leonine, isn't it? Yeah.
滚石乐队登台并在长途车站酒店演出。当时在场的另一位竞争对手推广人维克·杰尼斯对当晚的演出这样评价：“老实说，我当时不知道该对滚石乐队笑，还是该叫动物驯兽师来。我从来没见过这样的场面。”因为他们的声音实在是太吵了。那确实有很多呐喊。显然，米克·贾格尔的表演风格非常……他有点像狮子座，不是吗？是的。
Leonine later on Andrew Lugo old and compared him with a Puma. Actually. Yeah. Puma Puma is better, but he has this kind of main, I guess. Yes, exactly. And Kamelsky, the promoter who's doing this, he thinks they're very loud and raucous and disorganized, but, you know, they've got something. And his adverts for this night, which is every Sunday, start to play on the fact that Stones will be there and their reputation. And he writes this incredible kind of bullion copy, the inexhaustible purveyors of spontaneous combustion, the unmitigating ebullient perturbing rolling stones,
安德鲁·卢格·奥尔德姆后来把他比作美洲狮。其实是的。美洲狮，美洲狮更贴切，但他确实有着这种鬃毛般的发型。是的，没错。而负责操办这一切的推广人戈梅尔斯基认为他们声音又吵又闹又毫无纪律，但你知道，他们确实有点东西。他为这个每周日举行的晚会做的广告开始拿滚石乐队的到来和他们的声誉作文章。他写了一段极其精彩的夸张宣传文案：“自发燃烧的不竭供应商，无可妥协、兴高采烈且令人心神不宁的滚石，
or warning R&B sound barrier to be broken by rolling stones. Do you think this is why the Sex Pistols hated the stone so much? That they kind of looked at the stones and thought, that might be what we end up becoming. Yeah, I think so. I think that's the similarity, isn't it, that the Sex Pistols find alarming? Yeah, there's a real strong similarity.
或者警告：节奏布鲁斯声障将被滚石乐队打破。”你觉得这就是性手枪乐队那么讨厌滚石乐队的原因吗？他们看着滚石乐队，心里想：我们最后可能会变成那样。是的，我想是的。我想这就是那种让性手枪乐队感到警惕的相似之处吧，对吧？是的，确实有着非常强烈的相似之处。
So by the spring of 1963, they're getting a reputation among blues fans in West London. And that's not a big group. All sex of them. Yeah, exactly. Well, I mean, we get the first press cutting ever about the Rolling Stones in April 1963 in the Richmond and Twickenham Times. And this newspaper says there's a thing going on at this station hotel 300 people they're getting now every Sunday with long hair, suede jackets, gaucho trousers and Chelsea boots.
所以到了1963年春天，他们在西伦敦的布鲁斯乐迷中建立起了名声。但这并不是一个庞大的群体。总共也就六个人。是的，正好。好吧，我是说，我们在1963年4月的《里士满与特威克纳姆时报》上看到了关于滚石乐队的第一篇报纸剪报。这家报纸报道说，在那个车站酒店正在发生一些事情，现在每个星期天都会吸引300人去那儿，他们都留着长发，穿着麂皮夹克、高乔裤和切尔西靴。
I don't actually know what gaucho trousers are. No, but you've been to Argentina, surely you're not sporting a pair of gaucho trousers as you strutted. I actually went horse riding in Argentina. Did you? But I don't remember any special trousers. There might have been some chaps or something like that, but um. God, I don't want to imagine you in chaps.
我其实不知道高乔裤是什么。不知道，但你去过阿根廷，你大摇大摆的时候肯定没穿过高乔裤吧。我其实在阿根廷骑过马。是吗？但我不记得有什么特别的裤子。可能穿过一些护腿皮套或者类似的东西，不过……天哪，我可不想想象你穿护腿皮套的样子。
Brilliant. The other thing is that this point, the first appearance in the press is also the first point where people comment on their appearance. Their hair worn Piltdown style brushed forward from the crown like the Beatles pop group. And Piltdown style. Piltdown man. Yeah, Piltdown man. Friend of the show. Do you want to and Piltdown style. Piltdown man. Yeah. Piltdown man friend of the show.
太棒了。另一件事是，这个时候，他们在媒体上的首次亮相，也是人们对他们的外表发表评论的开端。“他们的头发梳成‘皮尔当人’风格，从头顶向前梳，就像甲壳虫乐队那样。”“皮尔当人风格”。皮尔当人。是的，皮尔当人。节目的老朋友。你想……还有皮尔当人风格。皮尔当人。是的，皮尔当人，节目的老朋友。
Do you want to explain Piltdown man very quickly, Tom, to people who didn't hear that episode. Yeah. Fake prehistoric man. The missing link discovered in Sussex. Exactly. So the comparison with Stone Age man, which you hear a lot in the sixties, but also obviously the comparison with the Beatles.
汤姆，你想不想给那些没听过那一期节目的听众快速解释一下什么是“皮尔当人”。好的。伪造的史前人类。在苏萨克斯发现的“缺失的环节”。完全正确。所以，将他们与石器时代的人进行对比——你在六十年代经常能听到这种说法，当然，还有与甲壳虫乐队的对比。
So right from the beginning, they're being held to that standard. And as it happens, the very next day, who should come to see them play? But the Beatles, the Beatles have been filming for TV nearby in Teddington, and they've heard that there's this band and they come to see them at this hotel to sign actually of how relatively unfamous the Beatles are at this point. They're famous enough to be filming for TV, but not so famous that they can't go to a hotel to watch a you know a little local band and they go there and the Stones are very excited that the Beatles who are what a year or so older maybe max you know little more than that roughly the same age but far more famous. The Stones are very excited they
所以从一开始，他们就被拿来和那个标准作比较。碰巧的是，第二天谁来看他们演出呢？正是甲壳虫乐队。甲壳虫乐队当时正在附近的泰丁顿为电视节目拍摄外景，他们听说有这么一支乐队，于是来到这家酒店观看演出——这其实也说明了当时甲壳虫乐队的知名度相对还没那么高。他们虽然出名到可以拍电视节目了，但还没红到不能去一家酒店看一支当地的小乐队。他们去了，滚石乐队感到非常兴奋，因为甲壳虫乐队只比他们大了一岁左右，最多大不了多少，年龄大致相当，但名气要大得多。滚石乐队非常兴奋，他们
actually try to impress the Beatles afterwards by saying listen to this and they'll play random blues numbers that the Beatles have never heard of and are not interested in. So the Stones are desperately trying to sort of suck up to them but the Beatles are very nice to them. The Beatles say look we're playing at the Royal Albert Hall in a couple of weeks would you like free tickets? The Stones don't find that condescending they're delighted they're very excited. I mean but it is a brilliant thing to play at the upper hall, isn't it, Dominic? It is. We should do that to other history podcasts. Actually, we don't want to because I don't want to set up a Rolling Stones to our Beatles. That would be terrible.
甚至在演出结束后试图给甲壳虫乐队留下深刻印象，放起了甲壳虫乐队从未听过也毫无兴趣的随机布鲁斯歌曲。所以滚石乐队当时在拼命地巴结他们，但甲壳虫乐队对他们非常好。甲壳虫乐队说：“听着，我们几周后要在皇家阿尔伯特音乐厅演出，你们想要免费门票吗？”滚石乐队并不觉得这是一种屈尊俯就，他们欣喜若狂，兴奋不已。我是说，能在阿尔伯特音乐厅演出绝对是一件了不起的事，对吧，多米尼克？确实如此。我们应该对其他历史播客也这么干。其实我们不想这么做，因为我可不想让我们的播客成为滚石对甲壳虫那种关系。那可太糟糕了。
Bill Wyman in his memoir says, Jagger and Richards idolized the Beatles and were starstruck by them. And I think this, you can argue this is a key moment for them, because this is a point when they, for the first time, meet people who have had the success of which they dream. And it's a point at which they glimpse, perhaps for the first time, what it would be like to become stars. And then just two weeks later comes the moment and the meeting that really changes their lives. So if the Richmond Station Hotel is the Rolling Stones' cavern, who will be their Brian Epstein? Find out after the break.
比尔·怀曼在他的回忆录中说：“贾格尔和理查兹对甲壳虫乐队顶礼膜拜，在他们面前就像见到了大明星一样惊叹不已。”我认为，你可以说这是他们人生中的一个关键时刻，因为正是在这个时间点，他们生平第一次遇到了那些取得了他们梦寐以求的巨大成功的人。也是在这个时候，他们或许第一次隐约看到了成为巨星会是怎样一种体验。然后仅仅两周后，那个真正改变他们命运的时刻和会面就来了。所以，如果里士满车站酒店是滚石乐队的“洞穴俱乐部”（Cavern Club），谁会是他们的布赖恩·艾普斯坦呢？中场休息后为您揭晓。
I'd never seen anything like it. They came on to me. The music reached out and went inside me. Totally. It satisfied me. I was in love. I heard what I'd always wanted to hear. I wanted it. It already belonged to me. Everything I'd done up until now was a preparation for this moment. I saw and heard what my life thus far had been for." So that was Andrew Lug Oldham, the Rolling Stones' first real manager, Dominic, remembering the moment on the 28th of April, 1963, when he heard them play for the first time. The kind of equivalent in the Stone story of Brian Epstein walking down into the cavern,
“我从未见过那样的场面。他们向我走来。音乐触碰并深入了我的内心。完全地。它满足了我。我坠入爱河了。我听到了我一直渴望听到的声音。我渴望得到它。它本来就属于我。我之前所做的一切都是为了这一刻做准备。我看到并听到了我迄今为止的人生究竟是为了什么。”这就是安德鲁·卢格·奥尔德姆，滚石乐队真正的第一任经纪人，多米尼克，他在回忆1963年4月28日第一次听到他们演奏时的情景。这在滚石的故事里，就相当于布赖恩·艾普斯坦走进洞穴俱乐部
seeing the Beatles for the first time. And the amazing thing about him, he's Dutch. Well, was that what that was? Yeah, it was kind of my approximation to a Dutch. I'd never seen anything. How does a Dutch person with this, says for sure a lot. And does that sort of strange, they do that, don't they? That's what I was trying to convey. Maybe it didn't work. Well, he was the son of a Dutch American air officer. He didn't actually talk with a Dutch accent. He went to private school. He definitely didn't come out of a British private school speaking like a Dutchman. That would have been beaten out of him. He'd been beaten with his own clogs, surely.
第一次看到甲壳虫乐队。而关于他最神奇的一点是，他是荷兰人。等等，那是怎么回事？好吧，那是我对荷兰口音的模仿。“我从未见过……”一个荷兰人说话会这样吗？会有很多“for sure”。那种奇怪的腔调，他们会那样说话，对吧？这就是我试图传达的感觉。也许没模仿好吧。好吧，他是荷兰裔美国空军军官的儿子。他其实并不带荷兰口音。他上的是私立学校。他绝对不可能从英国私立学校出来时操着一口荷兰腔。那样的话他早就挨揍了。他肯定会被自己的木鞋狠狠砸过吧。
So Andrew Lou Goldham, who's their first manager, he goes to see them play on the 28th of April, 1963. He is a tremendously amusing character. His autobiography, like Bill Wyman's is a cracking read. He's a very wily man. He's very driven and ruthless. His own autobiography approvingly quotes one of his critics calling him calculatedly vicious and nasty, but as pretty as a stoat. Is a stoat that the look that you strive for?
所以安德鲁·卢格·奥尔德姆作为他们的第一任经纪人，在1963年4月28日去观看了他们的演出。他是一个极其有趣的人物。他的自传和比尔·怀曼的一样，读起来非常过瘾。他是个极其精明狡猾的人。他非常有进取心且冷酷无情。他自己的自传中还赞许地引用了一位批评家对他的评价，称他“处心积虑地恶毒和讨厌，但像白鼬一样漂亮”。“白鼬”是你们追求的外貌吗？
I don't know. Maybe it is. If it's a hot stoat is the look that you strive for. I don't know. Maybe it's a hot stote. Yeah. So after private school, he'd left early. He'd worked as an odd job boy for Mary Quant, the fashion designer. We talked about in our 60s fashion episodes, and then he'd worked as a sort of gopher for various pop promoters. People who are promoting Bob Dylan, working for people
我不知道。也许是吧。如果说火辣的白鼬是追求的外貌的话。我不知道，也许是一只火辣的白鼬。好吧。所以从私立学校早早退学后，他曾在时装设计师玛丽·奎恩（我们之前在六十年代时尚单集里聊过）手下当过杂工，后来又给各种流行音乐推广人当过跑腿的。比如为鲍勃·迪伦做推广的人，为甲壳虫乐队做推广的人手下工作。他真的很想成为菲尔·斯佩特。这是一个……他戴着一顶奇怪的假发。听着，我不是在赞同这种做法，我只是说那是他的状态，你知道，他当时就在那个阶段。我只是在陈述事实。那是他的梦想。
who are promoting the Beatles. He really wants to be Phil Spector. That's a prison. He was where a weird wig. Look, I mean, I'm not approving of it. I'm just saying that's what it, you know, that's where he was at. I'm just reporting. That was his dream.
我只是在还原历史，汤姆。事情就是这样的。人们总会做出糟糕的选择。我能说什么呢？他想要组建自己的乐队来与甲壳虫乐队分庭抗礼。他从一个音乐产业内部人士那里听说：去里士满的车站酒店看看吧。多米尼克，我觉得这里有一个非常经典的“滑动门”时刻，对吧？
I'm just reporting history, Tom. That's how it is. People make bad choices. What can I say? He wants his own band to rival the Beatles. He's heard from a new sort of music industry insider. Go down to the station hotel in Richmond. And Dominic, I think there's a real kind of sliding doors moment there, isn't there?
因为这个俱乐部，他去那里是因为它正好在通往他居住的弗格内尔的同一条线路上。是的。所以很容易到达。没错。所以如果那不在同一条线路上，他去那里是因为它正好在通往……他居住的弗格内尔的同一条线路上。是的。所以很容易到达。没错。所以如果那不在同一条线路上，他就不会去，历史就会完全不同。历史就会完全不同。根本不会听到米克·贾格尔的名字。他现在会在干什么？谁知道呢？他会成为一个英语老师，不是吗？他可能会成为一个体育老师，就像他……就像他父亲一样，不过不会去伦敦政治经济学院。你不会去伦敦政治经济学院的，对吧？不会，他会去教经济学。是的，他会。他会成为一名顶尖的经济学家。他去那家酒店……他确实会。他会成为一名顶尖的经济学家。
Because this club, he goes there because it's on the same line as Frognell where he lived. Yeah. So it's easy to get to. Exactly. So if that hadn't been on the same line, he goes there because it's on the same line as, um, Frognell where he lived. Yeah. So it's easy to get to exactly. So if that hadn't been on the same line, he wouldn't have gone and history would have been different. History would have been different. Never heard of Mick Jagger. What would he be doing now? Who knows? He'd be an English teacher, wouldn't he? He'd be a PE teacher, maybe like his, uh, like his father, not at the LSC though. You wouldn't go to the LSC in it. No, he'd be teaching economics. Yeah, he would. He'd be a top economist. He goes down to this hotel on, he would. He'd be a top economist.
他去那家酒店。在入口处，他撞上了一个正在和女友吵架的年轻人。他对这个年轻人的描述是：“他很瘦，没有腰身，有着美洲狮的人形，却兼具雌雄莫辨的气质。”这真是一句绝妙的描写。这就是米克·贾格尔，你看。这确实是对米克·贾格尔非常贴切的描述。你说得太对了。如果你读到这句话，有人会问：“这是谁？”这显然就是米克·贾格尔。不管怎样，他走了进去，半小时后，乐队开始演奏了。
He goes down to this hotel. On the way in, he bumps into a young man who's having an argument with his girlfriend. He describes the young man. He was thin, waistless, giving him the human form of a puma with the gender of its own. That is a brilliant sentence. And this is Mick Jagger, you see. And it's a very good description of Mick Jagger. You're really right. If you read that sentence, someone said, who's this? That's clearly Mick Jagger. Anyway, he goes in, half an hour later, the band start playing.
现在，安德鲁·卢格·奥尔德姆对音乐一窍不通。他参与这行唯一的目的就是把它当作赚钱的工具。我挺喜欢音乐推广人这一点的。是的。我是说，他的目标非常明确。他走进去，然后他说：“哦，这简直太棒了。”就是你刚才用那口可爱的荷兰腔读过的那段名言。他游说他们签了一份为期三年的合同。顺便说一下，他当时只有19岁。
Now, Andrew Lou Goldham knows nothing at all about music. He's only interested in this as a vehicle to make money. I like that in the music promoter. Yeah. I mean, he's got his eyes on the prize. And he goes in and then he says, oh, this is absolutely amazing. That quotation that you read in your lovely Dutch accent. He persuades them to sign a three year contract. Now I should say he's only 19 years old.
我的天，他们竟然和一个什么都不懂的家伙签了三年合同，这简直太疯狂了，但他能说会道，而且他找了一个合伙人，一个老同学埃里克·伊斯顿，他来自兰开夏郡，就像我们深爱的执行制作人托尼·帕斯塔一样。所以他深谙音乐产业的各种门道。他就是那种所有乐队都需要、却又无法被归入“六0年代是革命年代”这种宏大叙事里的人。所以他不够时髦？
Yeah. I mean, it's bonkers that they've signed a three year contract with this man who knows nothing about anything, but he talks the talk and he finds a partner, an old school partner called Eric Easton, who's from Lancashire like our own beloved executive producer, Tony Pasta. So he knows all the nuts and bolts of the music industry. He's the kind of person that all bands had, but that doesn't fit into the sort of, oh, the 60s was an age of revolution account. So he's not groovy?
不，但他是个……你知道，他是那种会说：“嘿，顺便说一句，我知道这行怎么运作。你签了这份合同，然后这么做……”的人，而这正是你需要的。汤姆，我们在历史的其余部分不也这样吗？我们绝对是这样的。所以，埃里克·伊斯顿和安德鲁·卢格·奥尔德姆安排了一次与迪卡唱片的迪克·罗的会面。你刚才在上半场提到过他。他就是那个拒绝了甲壳虫乐队的人。
No, but he's, you know, he's the kind of person who says, Hey, and by the way, you know, I know how this works. You sign this deal, you do this, you know, that's what you need. Tom, do we not have that with the rest of history? We absolutely do. So Eric Easton, Andrew Lou Goldham arranged a meeting with Dick Rowe at Decker. And you mentioned him in the first half. He's the man who turned down the Beatles.
而迪克·罗当时正在寻找乐队。他想要尽可能多的乐队。碰巧的是，迪克·罗最近刚和乔治·哈里森一起在利物浦担任过一场才艺秀的评委。乔治·哈里森曾对他说过：“我前几天去里士满车站酒店看了一支乐队。他们挺不错的，叫滚石乐队。”所以当滚石乐队去找他时，他说：“太好了，行，这棒极了。”
And Dick Rowe is looking for groups. He wants as many groups as he can get. And as it happens, Dick Rowe has recently been judging a talent show in Liverpool with George Harrison. And George Harrison had said to him, I went to see this band at the station hotel in Richmond the other day. They were quite good, the Rolling Stones. And so when the Rolling Stones come to him, he says, great, right, brilliant.
你知道的，有什么理由拒绝呢？于是他签下了他们。就在这个时候，安德鲁·卢格·奥尔德姆做出了两项改变。首先，他说：“这个名字太烂了，‘滚石’。”对啊，你看，他也在担心这个问题。没错，就像你一样。对啊。他当时是怎么说的？
You know, what's not to like? And he signs them. Now at this point, Andrew Lou Golder makes two changes. First of all, he says, the name is rubbish. The Rolling Stones. Yeah, you see, he's worrying about that as well. Yeah, like you. Yeah. How well he said worrying about that as well. Yeah. Like you. Yeah.
他是怎么说的，我引用一下：“当你们连自己的名字都拼不对的时候，怎么能指望别人严肃对待你们？”我的天，他没说错。第二件事是，既然不叫滚石了……接下来，他说乐队里有六个人实在太多了。必须得有人走人。他说，伊恩·斯图尔特——就像你一样，汤姆，你们俩真的太像了，你和安德鲁·卢格·奥尔德姆。
How would he said, and I quote, how can you expect people to take you seriously when you can't even spell your name properly? I mean, he's not wrong. So the second thing is it said that it didn't become the rolling stones. Now, the next thing is that, um, he says six people in the band is far too many. Like someone's got to go. And he says, uh, Ian Stewart, like you, Tom, again, very similar people, you and Angela Goldham.
他说：“伊恩·斯图尔特，他长得不好看。他太丑了，必须得走人。让他滚蛋。”我不觉得他丑。我是说，如果你喜欢巨大的方下巴，他能嚼碎一根钢梁或者类似的东西而且毫无压力，但我能理解，他确实和滚石乐队那种雌雄同体的外形不太搭。绝对的。然后他们对斯图尔特说：“哦，真的很抱歉，你得离开乐队了。”而他说：“好吧，没问题，我留下来给你们开车，当你们的巡演经理吧。”这真的太暖心了。
He says, um, in Stuart, he's ugly. He's too ugly and he's got to go. Get rid. I don't think he's ugly. I mean, I think if you like massive square jaws, he'd chew on a girder or something like that and have no problem with that, but I mean, I can see it doesn't blend in with the kind of androgynous look of the stones. Exactly. Now they say to Stuart, oh, I'm so sorry, you've got to go. And he says, well, fine, I'll stay on and I'll drive you about and I'll be your road manager, which is so sweet.
他真的是个很高尚的人，对吧？他后来好像确实和查理·沃茨以及亚历克西斯·科纳一起组过乐队，对吗？是的，他们的确组过。所以这挺好的。是的。他开车四处奔波，为他们处理各种事务，悉心照顾他们长达20年之久。我必须得说，布赖恩·琼斯曾答应过给他所有收入的六分之一。结果给兑现了吗？没有，根本没给。太糟糕了。不管怎样，我们现在推进到了1963年5月左右。这正是“披头士狂热”（Beatlemania）在英国全面爆发的时期。显然，安德鲁·卢格·奥尔德姆做出了顺理成章的决定。他决定把他们包装得跟甲壳虫乐队一模一样。于是他带他们去了卡纳比街。
He's such a noble guy, isn't he? He does end up in a band, I think, with Charlie Watts, doesn't he? And Alexis corner. Yeah, they did indeed. So that's good. Yeah. And he drove around and did stuff for them and helped look after them for 20 years. I have to say Brian Jones promised him that he would get a sixth of everything. And did he? No, he didn't. That's bad. Anyway, we've now got to about May 1963. Now this is the point where Beatlemania is taking off in Britain. And obviously Andrew Lou Goldham does the obvious thing. He decides to make them just like the Beatles. So he takes them to Carnaby street.
他给他们弄了丝绒夹克、小领带和古巴跟皮鞋。而他们对这一切厌恶至极。统一的制服。他还让基思·理查兹把姓氏改成“基思·理查·理查兹”，这样听起来更像克里夫·理查德。我的天，这太疯狂了吧？听上去更有流行乐的感觉。他们经常被搞混。
He gets them velvet sort of jackets and little ties and Cuban heels. And they absolutely hate it. Matching uniforms. He gets Keith Richards to change his surname to Keith Richard. So he will sound more like Cliff Richard. I mean, that's mad, isn't it? It has a more pop sound. They're often confused.
他开始在音乐杂志上发表文章。比如一个很好的例子，《唱片镜报》（Record Mirror）1963年5月的一篇文章说，他们的风格是：“全新的丛林音乐，他们的演唱和演奏方式，比起一群狂野、令人兴奋的白人男孩，更像是人们对某个有色人种美国乐队的期望。”这其实非常重要。我之前说过我们会解释为什么滚石乐队会引起这么大的争议。我觉得这真的非常重要，人们从一开始就指出他们在演奏黑人音乐。这在当时是前所未有的。
He starts placing articles in the music press. So a very good example, Record Mirror, May 1963, their style, it says is quote, the new jungle music, they sing and play in a way that one would have expected more from a colored US group than a bunch of wild, exciting white boys. And this is actually important. I said we would explain why the Stones are so controversial. I think this is actually really important that people say from the very beginning, they are playing, you know, black music. This is unprecedented.
嗯，这正是摇滚乐对米克·贾格尔评价的那句名言。没错。在这档播客里我觉得无法引用，汤姆。确实无法引用，是的。但这是一个非常慢热的开端。他们度过了1963年的夏天。
Well, that's the great quote in the Rock and Rolls fendle about Mick Jagger. Exactly. Unquotable, I think, on this podcast, Tom. Very much unquotable, yes. But it's a very slow start. They spend the summer of 63. the Rock and Rolls fendle about Mick Jagger. Exactly. Unquotable, I think, on this podcast, Tom. Very much unquotable, yes. But it's a very slow start. They spend the summer of 63. They're doing this long provincial tour.
他们进行着漫长的英国地方巡演。这就是那个年代摇滚乐运作的方式。他们为像埃弗利兄弟这样的艺人在英国巡演担任暖场嘉宾，而且他们去的都是最疯狂、最小的场馆。所以最让我津津乐道的是我一直很喜欢的这个故事。他们在伊顿合作社舞厅演出，他们被安排为该镇贿赂学校儿童的下午茶活动进行伴奏。当他们走上台开始演奏这种音乐时，这些实际上只有八岁的小孩子们竟然集体用奶油蛋糕砸他们。
And this is how rock worked in those days. They're supporting people like the Everly Brothers touring Britain, and they are playing the maddest, tiniest venues. So my favorite one, I always love this story. They played the co-op ballroom, none eaten, and they were playing, they were booked to play at an afternoon tea for the town's bribery school children. And when they came on stage and they start playing this music, these children who are literally eight years old, all threw cream cakes at them.
哦天哪。这不过是摇滚乐罢了。比尔·怀曼在他的回忆录里提到了这件事。他提到过：“这太糟糕了。我讨厌这样。”糕点像雨点般从八岁小孩手里砸下来。是的。人们总是喋喋不休地谈论阿尔塔蒙特音乐节，但伊顿的这次经历才是真正黑暗的时刻。
Oh dear. It's only rock and roll. Bill Wyman mentions this in his, he mentions this in his memoir. He said, you know, it was terrible. I hate it. Pastries raining down from those eight year olds. Yeah. People go on about Altamont, but this non-eating is the real, the real dark moment.
不管怎样，这招确实管用，因为这就是你建立全国知名度的方式。所以他们的第一支单曲——翻唱自查克·贝里的《Come On》——在6月份最高只冲到排行榜第21位，但到了12月，他们的第二支单曲《I Wanna Be Your Man》（保罗·麦卡特尼送给他们的歌）冲到了第12位，人们开始在这个时候注意到他们了。于是全国性报纸《每日速写报》（Daily Sketch）在1964年1月提醒其读者：“当心这支长着像毛茸茸布丁盆一样脑袋的新乐队。”不得不说，60年代音乐新闻业的水准真是绝了。太棒了。我觉得当时的这种报道更多，而且更……
Anyway, this actually works because this is how you build a national reputation. So their very first single, which was come on a Chuck Berry cover had only peaked at number 21 in June, but by December, their second single, which is I want to be your man, which was given them by Paul McCartney gets to number 12 and people are starting to notice them at this point. So the Daily Sketch National newspaper January 1964 says to its readers, watch out for this new band with heads like hairy pudding basins. Got to say the standard of music journalism in the 60s was superb. Well, brilliant. There's more of it I think and it's more...
更有风趣。是的，很有意思，因为这一切都是崭新的，你看。一切都是崭新的。而且内容更多，我觉得，也更……
It's wittier. Yeah, it's fun because it's all new you see. It's all new. It's more of it, I think, and it's more. It's wittier. Yeah, it's fun because it's all new. You see, it's all new. It's gear. Yeah. Now, there's one really big development at this point hugely important for the Rolling Stones, which is the rise of Mick Jagger and the decline of Brian Jones. So Mick Jagger has all this time been at the LSE.
更有风趣。是的，很有趣，因为一切都是崭新的。你看，一切都是崭新的。太棒了。是的。好了，这个时候有一个非常重大的发展，对滚石乐队至关重要，那就是米克·贾格尔的崛起与布赖恩·琼斯的衰落。米克·贾格尔这段时间一直都在伦敦政治经济学院。
He's been a registered student at the LSE and he doesn't drop out until the end of September 1963 when he writes a letter to his tutors. I've been offered, I can't do his voice, I've been offered a really excellent opportunity in the entertainment world, he says. Now, up to this point, they had very obviously been Brian Jones's band, a blues band. Jones had put them together. Jones had booked the gigs. Jones had collected the money and doled it out, keeping the lion share, I have to say for himself.
他一直是伦敦政治经济学院的注册学生，直到1963年9月底他给导师写了一封信才正式退学。信中写道：“我得到了一次……我学不了他的声音……我得到了一个在娱乐界非常棒的发展机会。”在此之前，这显然是布赖恩·琼斯的乐队，是一支布鲁斯乐队。是琼斯把他们凑到了一起的。是琼斯预定演出场地的。是琼斯收钱并把钱分发给大家的，不过我得说，他自己拿走了最大的一份。
But at exactly this point, he starts to lose his position. He starts to be pushed out a little bit, basically because he's a complete flake. He doesn't have the temperament or the stamina to tour and play full time. He keeps collapsing with nervous exhaustion. The other stones say he's a hypochondriac. They're always making jokes about, oh, has he got a doctor's letter? Is he going to let it from his mom to let himself off rehearsing or whatever? But crucially, Andrew Lou Goldham says to them, playing old blues classics will not
但正是在这个时候，他开始失去自己的地位。他开始被边缘化，被挤出一小步，主要是因为他这人太不靠谱了。他没有全职巡演和演出的性格或耐力。他经常因为神经衰弱而瘫倒。其他滚石乐队成员都说他是疑病症患者。他们总是一起开玩笑说：“哦，他又拿到医生证明了吗？他是不是要拿他妈妈写的假条来逃避排练什么的？”但至关重要的是，安德鲁·卢格·奥尔德姆对他们说：“演奏古老的布鲁斯经典是行不通的。我们处在一个新时代，新的观众期望能像甲壳虫乐队那样自己写歌。”所以，贾格尔和理查兹就说：“太棒了，我们很乐意尝试自己写歌。”而布赖恩·琼斯却不想这么干。事实上，米克·贾格尔后来说的话稍微有点不够厚道，我觉得这么说挺公允的，他说：“布赖恩做不到这一点。”
cut it. We're in a new age and a new audience expects people to write their own songs as the Beatles do. So, you know, Jagger and Richards say, oh, brilliant. We'd love to try writing our own songs. And Brian Jones doesn't want to do that. In fact, Mick Jagger slightly ungallantly, I think it's fair to say, said later, Brian couldn't do that.
说实话，布赖恩在写歌方面毫无天赋，米克太太如是说。一点也没有。我从来没见过哪个家伙在写歌方面这么没有天赋，米克太太说。一点也没有。我从来没见过哪个家伙在词曲创作上这么缺乏天赋，这话说得真够严厉的。没错。而且对一个……好吧，现在这个人也无法还嘴了。不管怎样，不管怎样，贾格尔和理查兹搬进了安德鲁·卢格·奥尔德姆的公寓。布赖恩·琼斯被独自留下了。
To be honest, Brian had no talent for writing songs, said Mrs. Mick. None. I've never known a guy with less talent for writing songs said Mrs. Mick. None. I've never known a guy with less talent for songwriting, which is harsh. Right. About a man. Well, and now can't answer back. Anyway, anyway, Jack and Richard's move into a flat with Andrew Lou Goldham. Brian Jones has left on his own.
所以他更加被边缘化了。正如比尔·怀曼在他的自传中所说：“布赖恩试图通过先向米克摇尾乞怜、然后再向安德鲁摇尾乞怜来博取欢心，但这毫无用处，他本该坚守自我。”所以你会发现，他们真是一群霸凌者。好吧，布赖恩·琼斯，你看，我觉得布赖恩·琼斯太糟糕了，考虑到他糟糕的行为，他们已经表现得相当有耐心了。
So he's even more marginalized. And as Bill Wyman says in his autobiography, Brian would try to ingratiate himself by crawling first to Mick and then to Andrew, which didn't do any good, he should simply have been strong in himself. So you find this, there's such a bunch of bullies. Well, Brian Jones, see, I think Brian Jones is terrible and they behave remarkably patient given his poor behavior.
不管怎样，情况就是这样。是的。好吧，正如我一开始就说过的那样，我们要探讨他们为什么会引发如此巨大的争议。他们从踏上全国舞台的那一刻起就伴随着争议。他们在1963年7月的一档名为《感谢你的幸运星》的杂耍类电视节目的最底层进行了电视首秀。他们当时还穿着配套的制服。他们穿着格子夹克和休闲裤，就像中西部大学的讲师，美国大学的历史讲师那样，熨烫得笔挺、裤线笔直的
But anyway, there you go. Yeah. Well, now from the start, I said, we'd get into why they're so controversial. They had been controversial from the moment they stepped onto the national stage. So they'd made their television debut at the very bottom of the bill on a kind of variety show called thank your lucky stars in July, 1963. They were still in their matching outfits. They were in checked jackets and slacks like lecturers at a Midwestern university, history lecturers at an American university, nice chinos or something, ironed with creases down the
那种。尽管他们穿着这身行头，制作节目的ATV电视台还是收到了如雪片般飞来的信件，人们纷纷指责这是“绝对的耻辱”，我引用一下：“像这样长发披肩的流氓竟然被允许上电视，这简直令人发指。他们的外表绝对令人作呕。你们这群人全该好好洗个澡，把那些长发统统剪掉。你们肮脏的外表很有可能会带坏全国各地的青少年。”你知道吗，这种感觉就像英国曾经是个好玩得多的地方。不，我知道。奇怪的是，如果你去看……如果你看看他们，头发其实根本没有那么长。头发只是稍微长了一点。但每个人都是赢家，对吧？因为义愤填膺的人可以尽情发泄愤怒。是的。滚石乐队则变得危险刺激。是的。而他们其实并没有那么危险。
middle. And even though they were wearing these outfits, ATV who made the show were deluged with letters, people saying absolute disgrace. And I quote, it is disgusting that long haired louts such as these should be allowed to appear on television. Their appearance was absolutely disgusting. The whole lot of you should be given a good bath and all that hair should be cut off. Your filthy appearance is likely to corrupt teenagers all over the country. Do you know the sense that Britain was a much more fun place? No, I know. The weird thing is when you watch the, if you look at them, the hair really isn't that
每个人都是赢家。不，绝对的，汤姆。每个人都……他们其实并没有那么危险，每个人都是赢家。不，绝对的，汤姆，每个人都玩得很开心。我觉得他们跟以前相比也赚了好多钱，所以他们都……你知道的，都很兴奋。当然，这是甲壳虫乐队的夏天。我觉得这里的背景非常重要，但甲壳虫乐队是主流。
long. Very slightly long hair. But everyone wins, don't they? Because outraged people can be outraged. Yeah. The stones get to be dangerous. Yeah. And they're not really.
甲壳虫乐队凭借布赖恩·艾普斯坦的营销、他们巨大的知名度，当然尤其是当他们进行诸如皇家综艺演出，或者去美国征服美国排行榜时，他们变成了某种民族英雄。你刚才还在嘲笑亚历克西斯·道格拉斯-休姆（Alec Douglas-Home）。亚历克西斯·道格拉斯-休姆特意对甲壳虫乐队大加赞赏。他说，如果有人问为什么甲壳虫乐队会成功，我可以告诉你，那是因为他们是一群非常自然、非常有趣的年轻人。顺便说一句，关于他们很有趣这一点，这是甲壳虫乐队和滚石乐队之间一个巨大的区别。滚石乐队从来——他们可能会无意中显得滑稽，但他们从来没有真正像甲壳虫乐队那样有趣过，对吧？
And everyone's a winner. No, absolutely, Tom. Everyone's They're not really, and everyone's a winner. No, absolutely. Tom, everyone's having a great time. I think they're also, they've got so much money, I think by comparison with what they had before. So they're all, you know, they're all excited. Now this is of course the summer of the Beatles. And I think the context of this really matters, but the Beatles are mainstream.
是的。我是说，他们在私底下可能挺有趣的。是的。但在采访中，他们可不会那样插科打诨、开玩笑。那种“你们是怎么发现美国的？”“在格陵兰岛向左转”的梗。太爆笑了。哦，太精彩的胡侃了。所以我觉得发生的情况是，由于甲壳虫乐队占据了主流阵地，
The Beatles, thanks to Brian Epstein's marketing, their huge popularity and then of course especially when they do things like the Royal Variety Performance or when they go to America and conquer the American charts, they become kind of national heroes. You were laughing earlier about Sir Alec Douglas Hume. Sir Alec Douglas Hume goes out of his way to praise the Beatles. He says if anyone asks why the Beatles are successful I can tell you it is because they are a band of very natural, very funny young men. That thing about them being funny, by the way, that is one massive difference in the Beatles and the Stones. The Stones are never, they're unintentionally funny, but they're never really funny, are they, in the same way the Beatles are?
市场上显然出现了一个空白，需要这样一个更具颠覆性、更叛逆的乐队来填补。这就是长发的切入点。在他们出道前18个月左右的时间里，几乎每一篇关于滚石乐队的文章都会提到他们的头发。在20世纪中叶的英国，很大程度上由于第二次世界大战的遗留影响以及50年代国民兵役的普遍征兵制，长发被视为异端、肮脏、放荡、颠覆和波西米亚式的象征——所有这些标签。有什么理由不讨厌呢？人们对滚石乐队的长发确实感到被冒犯了。所以在1964年春天，这是一个令人惊叹的事件，
Yeah. I mean, they are funny, I guess, in private. Yeah. But in their interviews, they're not kind of bantering and joshing and all that kind of ring going away. How did you find America turned left at Greenland? Hilarious. Oh, amazing banter. So I think what's happened is because the Beatles have occupied the center ground,
全国美发师联合会召开了年度会议，该联合会主席在演讲中猛烈抨击了滚石乐队“散漫、肮脏且彻底破烂不堪的外表”。西奥非常希望我们开个玩笑，基本上这一集的故事就是“滚石乐队大战巨型发型”。所以这基本上就是“大长发”对阵“大美发”……或者说美发业。不管怎样，让人费解的是，甲壳虫乐队其实也留着长发，但他们的头发很干净。
there is clearly a gap in the market for a group that is more unsettling, more rebellious. And this is where the hair comes in. Almost every single article about the stones in their first 18 months or so mentioned the hair. In mid-century Britain, I think in large part as a legacy of the Second World War and the mass conscription involved in national service in the 1950s, Long hair is viewed as dissident, dirty, licentious, subversive, Bohemian, all of these kinds of things. What's not to like? And people really are offended by the stones here. So in spring 1964, this is an amazing
很有趣。是的。干净、古怪又好玩。我认为区别就在这里。甲壳虫乐队把自己塑造成滑稽、可爱、老少咸宜的形象，所以他们的长发显得古怪、奇特而具有娱乐性，而滚石乐队的长发则是危险和具有威胁性的。但我认为这也是因为音乐本身的性质。甲壳虫乐队的音乐是大家已经耳熟能详的。它是一种
the National Federation of Hairdressers held its annual conference and the president of the national federation of hairdressers devoted his speech to an assault on the Rolling Stones slovenly dirty and downright ragged appearance. Theo's very keen that we make the joke that basically the story of this episode is the Stones versus big hair. So it's basically big hair versus big hair. They kind of big or big hairdressing, I should say. Anyway, the puzzle actually is that the Beatles also have long hair, but that's clean.
全国美发师联合会召开了年度会议，全国美发师联合会主席在演讲中猛烈抨击了滚石乐队邋遢、肮脏和破破烂烂的外表。西奥非常希望我们开个玩笑，基本上这一集的故事就是滚石乐队对阵大牌美发。所以基本上是大牌美发对阵大牌美发。或者说大型美发行业，我应该这么说。总之，令人费解的是，披头士乐队其实也有长发，但那是干净的。
It's fun. Yes. It's clean and wacky and fun. Here's, I think the difference. The Beatles, because they present themselves as funny and cuddly and child-friendly, their long hair is eccentric and quirky and entertaining, whereas the Stones' long hair is dangerous and threatening. But I think it's also because of the nature of the music. The Beatles music is already familiar. It's a
这很有趣。是的。它既干净、古怪又充满乐趣。我认为区别在这里。披头士乐队因为把自己包装得风趣、可爱且老少咸宜，他们的长发就显得古怪、奇特而又具有娱乐性，而滚石乐队的长发则是危险且具有威胁性的。但我觉得这也是由音乐的本质决定的。披头士的音乐已经让人耳熟能详。它是一种
familiar style. It's not an alarming style of music because it's the beat music that has been around for a couple of years. The Stones music is rhythm and blues which has no chart history before 1964 and when people do talk about it they say what is it? Oh it's the music of poor black Americans and so people talk about it as kind of scruffy music, rebellious music and so I think even before the Stones have conquered the charts, before they've actually done anything wrong, the press are talking about them as bad boys, rebellious outlaws and so on. And for me, Andrew Lou Goldin's genius as a manager is having started out thinking I
熟悉的风格。这不是一种让人警觉的音乐风格，因为它是已经存在了几年的节拍音乐。滚石乐队的音乐是节奏布鲁斯，在1964年之前没有任何排行榜历史，当人们谈论它时，他们会说这是什么？哦，这是贫穷的黑人美国人的音乐，所以人们谈论它时，会把它当作一种粗俗的音乐、叛逆的音乐，所以我认为，甚至在滚石乐队征服排行榜之前，在他们实际做错任何事情之前，媒体就已经在把他们当作坏男孩、叛逆的逃犯等等来谈论了。对我来说，安德鲁·洛·奥尔德姆作为经理的天才之处在于，他一开始的想法是，我
will make them like the Beatles. He ditches that quite quickly and realizes we cannot possibly compete with them because they have such a massive head start. The gap in the market is for the anti-Beatles. It's for a group teenagers can have for themselves that will shock their parents. In his memoir, he says at the end of 1963, he consciously decided to turn the stones into quote, the group parents love to hate, dangerous, dirty, and degenerate. And he said to them, be as nasty as you can be in
会让他们像披头士乐队一样。他很快就放弃了这一点，并意识到我们根本无法与他们竞争，因为他们有着如此巨大的领先优势。市场上的空白是反披头士。这是一个青少年可以自己拥有的、会让父母感到震惊的群体。在他的回忆录中，他说在1963年底，他有意识地决定把滚石乐队变成所谓的“父母又爱又恨的群体，危险、肮脏且堕落”。他对他们说，在你们的
your interviews and your public performances. And he is the guy who's kind of spoon feeds titles like you know would you let your daughter go up with the Rolling Stone things like that to the press so it's very very calculated isn't it? Exactly and that's the interesting thing right people always at the time and afterwards have said well the Beatles were very commercialized they were manicured. The stones are more authentic because they're more rebellious. Actually that is totally wrong.
采访和公开表演中要表现得尽可能令人讨厌。他正是那种会向媒体喂食诸如“你会让你的女儿和滚石乐队的人交往吗”之类标题的人，所以这一切都是非常非常刻意计算的，对吧？一点没错，这正是最有趣的地方，对吧？当时和后来的很多人总是说，披头士非常商业化，他们被精雕细琢过。滚石则更具真实感，因为他们更叛逆。事实上，这完全是大错特错。
The stones is rebelliousness is completely contrived and manufactured. Can I just read you something that I, cause I didn't have time to dust down all my rolling stones books. So I turned to Bob Stanley's, yeah, yeah, yeah. Yeah. The kind of Plutarch's lives of popular music. Brilliant pen portraits of all the acts, including the Stones. He said, The youthful authority the Stones perceptively had, which even the Beatles lacked, resulted not
滚石的叛逆完全是刻意策划和人造出来的。我可以读一段我写的东西吗，因为我没有时间把所有关于滚石的书都拂去灰尘。所以我翻开了鲍勃·斯坦利的，对，对，对。对。那本通俗音乐的《名人传》。里面对包括滚石在内的所有艺人都进行了精彩的生动刻画。他说：“滚石敏锐地展现出的那股青春威严，连披头士都缺乏，其结果并非
from their knowledge of muddy waters, beach sides, but from their complete control of their image, sound and media angle from the start. Olden produced the records and designed the sleeves, while Jagger and Richards made sure there would be no pantos, no synchronized head shaking on stage, nothing predictable. Yeah. So it's the lack of predictability that enables their rise to become predictable. The contrivance, the manufacture is the lack of contrivance. If you know what I mean, there's a story, Oldham gets a guy called
来自他们对沃特斯（Muddy Waters）或海滩的了解，而是来自于他们从一开始就对自己的形象、声音和媒体角度的完全掌控。奥尔德姆制作唱片并设计封套，而贾格尔和理查兹则确保不会有哑剧表演，不会在舞台上有同步的摇头动作，没有任何可以预测的东西。”是的。所以正是这种缺乏可预测性，使得他们的崛起变得可以预测。这种刻意和制造，本质上就是对刻意的一种掩饰。如果你明白我的意思的话。有个故事，奥尔德姆找了一个叫
Gerard Mankiewicz, very well-known photographer to photograph them. And he says, you know, snarl more, make it more or pilt down, more pilt down, more moody, you know, look more angry and difficult. Whereas in fact, actually they're not especially angry and difficult off stage, but the media love this. Everyone's happy. It works for everybody. So by an early 1964, the media are playing along the daily Daily Express February 64. They look like boys
热拉尔·曼基维茨（Gerard Mankiewicz）的知名摄影师来为他们拍照。他说：“你知道的，笑得更凶点，凶狠一点，粗鲁一点，阴郁一点，你知道的，看起来更愤怒、更难对付一点。”然而事实上，他们在台下其实并不是特别愤怒和难对付，但媒体非常喜欢这一点。每个人都很高兴。这对所有人都管用。因此，到了1964年初，媒体开始配合。《每日快报》1964年2月写道：“他们看起来就像是任何一个注重体面的妈妈都会锁在浴室里的男孩，
whom any self-respecting mum would lock in the bathroom but the Rolling Stones five tough young London-based music makers with doorstep mouths, pallid cheeks and unkempt hair are not worried what mums think. So Mick must be thrilled at being called a tough young Londoner. Right but a weird thing is of course as we will see they do worry about what mums think, meaning their own mothers, because they're very filial. And the contrast of the Beatles becomes so explicit it becomes a cliché. Here's the news of the world, November 1964. The Beatles bubble with laughter, they make jokes, they wear neat clothes, they get along with royalty, but it's different with the Stones.
但滚石乐队——这五个有着厚嘴唇、苍白面颊和蓬乱头发的强硬年轻伦敦音乐制作人——并不在乎妈妈们怎么想。”所以米克一定为自己被称为一个强硬的伦敦年轻人而激动不已。对吧？但奇怪的是，正如我们后面将看到的，他们其实确实在乎妈妈们怎么想，指的是他们自己的母亲，因为他们非常孝顺。而且与披头士的对比变得如此直白，以至于成了一种陈词滥调。这是1964年11月的《世界新闻报》：“披头士充满欢笑，他们开玩笑，穿着整洁的衣服，与皇室成员相处融洽，但滚石乐队则不同。
They leer rather than smile, they don't wear natty clothes. And at the end of the piece, the journalist notes correctly, the extraordinary thing is that more and more youngsters are turning towards the stones. The Beatles have become too respectable. And it's that very respectability that the Beatles clearly do have in 1963, 64, that gives the stones their opportunity to cast themselves as the antithesis of it. Had the Beatles been less respectable actually, there would have been much less room, I think, for the Rolling Stones to make a name for themselves.
他们与其说是微笑，不如说是斜眼坏笑，他们不穿时髦的衣服。”在文章的末尾，这位记者正确地指出：“奇怪的是，越来越多的年轻人正转向滚石。披头士变得太死板、太体面了。”正是披头士在1963、1964年间明显拥有的那种体面，给了滚石将自己塑造为其对立面的机会。事实上，如果披头士不那么体面，我想滚石乐队扬名立万的空间就会小得多。
And of course the irony is, is the Beatles are authentically working class, and their apprenticeship had involved any number of pills and, you know, hanging out with prostitutes and brothels and all kinds of stuff. But all that has been buried. That has been buried, as has the Stones kinds of stuff. But all that has been buried. That has been buried as has the stones. Respectability. The LSE and all that. The Mick Jagger going to the LSE. The fact that Bill Wyman and Charlie Watts had held steady, serious jobs.
当然，讽刺的是，披头士其实是地地道道的工人阶级，他们的学徒生涯涉及了无数的药丸，你知道的，和妓女鬼混、出入妓院以及各种各样的事情。但这一切都被掩盖了。这一切都被掩盖了，就像滚石的那些事情一样。体面。伦敦政治经济学院（LSE）和那些东西。米克·贾格尔去伦敦政治经济学院上学。比尔·怀曼和查理·沃茨曾拥有稳定、严肃的工作这一事实。
The fact that Bill Wyman was married with a child. The fact that when journalists interview them, they say offstage, they are quiet and modest and Mick Jagger, their leader, Brian Jones would not have been happy with that. Mick Jagger, their leader, Brian Jones would not have been happy with that. Mick Jagger, their leader is unusually friendly and intelligent. That's from a book called the Teenage Revolution by Peter Lorry, 1965. Their parents, their family are really surprised at the criticism of them. Charlie Watts, his mother, he's always been a good boy.
比尔·怀曼结过婚并育有一子这一事实。当记者采访他们时，他们说在台下他们既安静又谦逊，而他们的领袖米克·贾格尔，布赖恩·琼斯才不会对这一点感到高兴呢。米克·贾格尔，他们的领袖，布赖恩·琼斯才不会对这一点感到高兴。米克·贾格尔，他们的领袖，出奇地友善且聪明。”这段话出自彼得·洛里1965年出版的名叫《青少年革命》的书。他们的父母、家人对外界对他们的批评感到非常惊讶。查理·沃茨的母亲说，他一直是个好孩子。
We've never had police knocking on the door. He's always been terribly kind to old people, which is good preparation for going on tour with the road. Bill Wyman's mom says, what's going on here? And Bill, she asked about his hair. And Bill Wyman says, I love this quote because it expresses, it basically expresses my worldview. Like how I approach everything. Bill says to his to his mom, it's only for about three years off his hair and I'll get a nice car and a nice house fully furnished out of it. You've put fully furnished in italics. Well, I think the fully furnished, it's like there's the banal practicality. Euterish quality.
我们从来没有遇到过警察来敲门。他对老年人一直都极其友善，这为他和巡演乐队一起上路做好了充分准备。”比尔·怀曼的妈妈说：“这到底是怎么回事？”比尔——她问起他的头发。比尔·怀曼说：“我很喜欢这句名言，因为它表达了，它基本上表达了我的世界观。就像我对待所有事情的方式一样。”比尔对他的妈妈说：“这头发也就留大约三年，然后我能用它换一辆好车和一套精装修的好房子。”你把“精装修”打成了斜体。好吧，我认为“精装修”这个词，就好像带有一种平庸的实用主义。
Exactly. Keith Richards always kept in touch with his mom when he went on tour and used to send her presents from the countries that he visited. Charlie Watts arranged to have his mum receive her favourite chocolate cake every Friday night. Isn't that nice? Yeah. John Lennon never behaved like that, Tom. He bought Aunt Mimi a house in Bournemouth.
市侩的品质。没错。基思·理查兹在巡演时总是和妈妈保持联系，并经常从他访问的国家给她寄礼物。查理·沃茨安排让他的妈妈每个星期五晚上都能收到她最喜欢的巧克力蛋糕。这不是很棒吗？是的。约翰·列侬可从来没有那样表现过，汤姆。他给米米阿姨在伯恩茅斯买了一栋房子。
He did. That's true. He did. The media, of course, aren't interested in any of that. Doesn't fit the personas and Oldham downplays it. And all that happens is their rebellious image becomes greater and greater. Every little incident, and of course there are bound to be lots of incidents because these are young men surrounded by adoring girls that drink, they're having fun.
他确实买过。那是真的。他买过。当然，媒体对这些全无兴趣。这不符合他们的人设，奥尔德姆也对此轻描淡写。发生的一切只是他们的叛逆形象变得越来越高大。每一个小插曲——当然注定会有很多小插曲，因为这是一群被崇拜的女粉丝包围、喝酒、寻欢作乐的年轻男子——
Later on of course there'll be drugs. So it's not like there aren't any incidents, it's not that there isn't any bad behavior, but it's massively magnified. And it's a strategy that works. In April 64, their album The Rolling Stones knocks with the Beatles off the top of the album charts. In July, it's all over now, becomes their first British hit single. In December 64, Little Red Rooster becomes the only blues song ever to top the British
后来当然还会有毒品。所以并不是说没有任何小插曲，并不是说没有任何不良行为，而是这一切被无限放大了。这是一个行之有效的策略。1964年4月，他们的专辑《滚石》把披头士赶下了专辑排行榜的榜首。7月，《这一切都结束了》（It's All Over Now）成为他们在英国的第一首热门单曲。1964年12月，《小红公鸡》（Little Red Rooster）成为唯一一首登上英国
singles charts. But Dominic, just to say that in turn then gets knocked off the top by, I feel fine by the Beatles, which has that kind of amazing feedback at its start, which is no one's ever done before. So the idea that the Beatles are conventional and the Stones are rebellious in musical terms, it's the Beatles who are, I mean, way, way ahead. I would agree with that. That said, there's just not the musical journey of the Beatles, but in the next
单曲排行榜榜首的布鲁斯歌曲。但是多米尼克，不得不说的是，那首歌随后就被披头士的《我感觉很好》（I Feel Fine）给赶下了榜首，这首歌开头有着那种惊人的回授效果，这是以前从未有人做过的。所以那种认为披头士是传统的、而滚石在音乐上是叛逆的观点——其实是披头士，我是说，远远、远远地走在前面。我同意这一点。虽说如此，他们虽然没有披头士那样的音乐历程，但在接下来的
18 months or so, they do have a pretty amazing run of singles, Heart of Stone, Play With Fire, Satisfaction, Get Off My Cloud, 19th Nervous Breakdown, Paint It Black and so on and so forth. But these are all their own, I mean, they're kind of their own songs, right? Yeah. And so that is taking them away from Brian Jones's vision. Exactly. Brian Jones is more and more unhappy with this because actually what they're no
18个月左右的时间里，他们确实创作了一系列相当惊人的单曲：《石头的心》（Heart of Stone）、《玩火》（Play With Fire）、《满足》（Satisfaction）、《滚开我的云》（Get Off My Cloud）、《第19次神经崩溃》（19th Nervous Breakdown）、《涂黑》（Paint It Black）等等。但这些全都是他们自己的，我是说，它们算是他们自己的歌，对吧？是的。所以这正在把他们带离布赖恩·琼斯的愿景。没错。布赖恩·琼斯对此越来越不高兴，因为实际上他们已经
longer doing is playing Chicago blues. They are evolving into a rock band, into something new, something that hasn't actually really existed before. I mean, imagine being unhappy that you've released Satisfaction as a single. So Satisfaction was their first US number one in 1965. Then they have their first US number one album out of our heads. A month later in October, 1965, when they released in America, December's
不再演奏芝加哥布鲁斯了。他们正在演变成一支摇滚乐队，演变成某种新的东西，某种以前实际上并不真正存在的东西。我的意思是，想象一下，因为你发行了单曲《满足》而感到不高兴。所以《满足》是他们在1965年的第一首美国冠军单曲。接着他们推出了在美国的第一张冠军专辑《走出我们的头脑》（Out of Our Heads）。一个月后，即1965年10月，当他们在美国发行《12月的
children, everybody's, which was their next album, the US title, it was advertised by a huge David Bailey poster in Times Square. So this is two years after they had been on that stage in non-eaten. Having kids. Having bums. By eight year olds. By eight year olds. I mean, that is bonkers.
孩子们，每个人》（December's Children (And Everybody's)）——这是他们的下一张专辑，也是美国版专辑名——时代广场上一个巨大的大卫·贝利海报为其做了广告。所以这是他们登上非伊顿公学舞台的两年后。生孩子的。有屁股的。八岁小孩干的。八岁小孩。我的天，这太荒谬了。
Because we now take their rise and that of the Beatles and groups like them for granted, we underestimate, I think, what an extraordinary thing that was. Not least because stuff like this had never happened before and certainly never happened to a British group. It might happen now all the time. So we're used to the trajectory and there's a sort of formula. But at the time people like the Rodding Stones had never even been to America on holiday. So to go and have your poster in Times Square at the age of what?
因为我们现在把他们以及披头士和类似乐队的崛起视为理所当然，所以我认为我们低估了这是一件多么非同寻常的事情。尤其是因为类似的事情以前从未发生过，而且绝对从未在一个英国乐队身上发生过。现在可能随时都在发生。所以我们习惯了这种轨迹，并且有某种公式。但在当时，像滚石乐队这样的人甚至连去美国度假都没有过。所以在什么年纪——
22, 23? I mean it's a mind boggling experience for them. And the interesting thing is when the Beatles did this, the Beatles came home and they were national champions, patriotic heroes, hurrah, you know, banner headlines, but the Stones never enjoy that reputation because they appear more cynical, more confrontational. What they've done is they've established something that I think is new, which is the image of the rock group as insolent,
22岁、23岁？——就能让你的巨幅海报出现在时代广场上？我的意思是，对他们来说这是一段令人匪夷所思的经历。有趣的是，当披头士做到这一点时，披头士回到国内成了民族英雄、爱国偶像，万岁，你知道的，醒目的头条新闻，但滚石从未享受过这种声誉，因为他们显得更加愤世嫉俗，更具对抗性。他们所做的是，我认为他们建立了一种新东西，那就是摇滚乐队那种傲慢的形象，
as representing aggression, sensuality, confrontation, generational discord. Well, that's the key thing, isn't it? And this is an occurring theme right the way up to the present, is that if you're a rebellious teenager, you don't want your parents digging what you're into. Yeah. But nobody had had that conversation before this point. No. So they invent that they effectively invent that they, I mean, the generation
代表着攻击性、感官性、对抗性、代际不和。嗯，这才是关键所在，不是吗？这是一个贯穿至今的持续主题，那就是如果你是一个叛逆的青少年，你不会希望你的父母对你着迷的东西评头论足。是的。但在这一点之前，没有人进行过这种对话。没有。所以他们发明了这一点，他们实际上发明了这一点，我——代际
gap, I think is massively inflated in the sixties, but there clearly is a market for a group that will annoy your dad. And the stones fill that gap perfectly. And actually at the point when they're conquering America, something happens in Britain that I think if you'd ask most adults in Britain in 1965, what's the one thing you know about the Rolling Stones? It is this story. So we'll end with this. Does this involve a micturation?
鸿沟，我认为在六十年代被极大地夸大了，但市场上确实存在一个会惹你爸爸生气的乐队群体。而滚石完美地填补了这一空白。事实上，就在他们征服美国的时候，英国发生了一件事，如果你在1965年问英国的大多数成年人，关于滚石乐队你所知道的一件事是什么，我想他们都会说这个故事。所以我们就以这个结束。这涉及排泄吗？
It does. Micturation. Oh, that's, that's what they pay you the big bucks for. Isn't it Tom? That kind of wordplay, witty wordplay. Yeah. Yeah. So in March 1965, they'd been giving a concert at the Romford Odeon. That's the other great thing about, about the sixties, right? Yeah. One minute. Times Square, you're in the Romford Odeon. That one minute you're doing something brilliant. And the next thing you're in that Boerum in the Newton again. And they've, they're Daimler, their chauffeur driven Daimler is bringing them back from Romford
确实涉及。排泄。哦，这就是，这就是他们花大价钱请你的原因。对吧，汤姆？那种双关语，机智的双关语。对。对。所以在1965年3月，他们在罗姆福德奥顿（Romford Odeon）举办了一场音乐会。这就是六十年代的另一个伟大之处，对吧？是的。前一分钟。在时代广场，而你身处罗姆福德奥顿。前一分钟你还在做着了不起的事。下一分钟你又回到了牛津的那个陋室里。他们坐着——他们的戴姆勒轿车，司机驾驶的戴姆勒轿车正载着他们从罗姆福德返回，
and they late at night and they stop at a service station, a garage, a gas station, as our overseas listeners would call it in Stratford, East London. And the garage manager, whose name was Charles Keighley, just later told a court that a shaggy haired monster got out of the car and asked quote in disgusting language if he could use the toilet and Keighley said no this person was Bill Wyman by the way married with a child living in Penj and then the other members of the band got out of the car too and started to argue with Charles Keighley and said come on you, can you let him use the toilets? We piss anywhere, man.
当时已经很晚了，他们在埃斯特伦敦斯特拉特福德的一个服务区、一个车库——正如我们海外听众所说的那样——停了下来。车库经理名叫查尔斯·凯利（Charles Keighley），他后来在法庭上作证说，一个满头乱蓬蓬头发的怪物从车里出来，用——原话——“令人作呕的语言”询问是否可以使用洗手间，凯利说“不行”。顺便说一句，这个人就是比尔·怀曼，已婚并育有一子，住在彭奇（Penge）。然后乐队的其他成员也下了车，开始和查尔斯·凯利争吵，并说：“得了吧，伙计，你能让他用一下厕所吗？我们到处都能撒尿，老兄。”
Yeah, Jagger comes out with this terrible line. We piss anywhere, man. But still they're trying, they're not insisting, they're bargaining with the petrol station staff and Charles Keely lost his temper and shouted, get off my forecourt. At which Brian Jones started dancing around the forecourt stations, shouting and shouted, get off my forecourt. At which Brian Jones started dancing around this forecourt stash stations, shouting and singing, get off my foreskin at the station, ma'am. Not get off my cloud. No, not get off my cloud.
是的，贾格尔说出了这句糟糕的台词：“我们到处都能撒尿，老兄。”但他们仍然在试探，他们不是在坚持，而是在跟加油站员工讨价还价。查尔斯·凯利发了脾气，大喊：“滚出我的前院！”这时布赖恩·琼斯开始在加油站前院跳起舞来，大喊大叫着喊道：“滚出我的包皮，老兄，在加油站里。”不是“滚出我的云”。不，不是“滚出我的云”。
Anyway, this episode in glorious as it may sound ended with Bill Wyman, Mick Jagger and Brian Jones urinating on the wall of the forecourt and then driving off in triumph in their Daimler. Charles Keighley brought a private prosecution against them. They were dragged into an East London courtroom and convicted of insulting behaviour liable to cause a breach of the peace and handed a very small fine. And was this all arranged by Oldham? Well, this is a brilliant, this is an amazingly trivial and pathetic story, but it was like
无论如何，这个听起来可能很光彩的插曲以比尔·怀曼、米克·贾格尔和布赖恩·琼斯在前院的墙上小便而告终，然后他们乘着戴姆勒轿车凯旋而去。查尔斯·凯利对他们提起了一桩私人诉讼。他们被拖进伦敦东区的法庭，并被判犯有容易导致破坏和平的侮辱性行为罪，并被处以非常轻微的罚款。这一切都是奥尔德姆安排的吗？好吧，这是一个绝妙的、极其琐碎且可悲的故事，但它就像是
front page headlines, stones, shame, but massive for their reputation, a massive, massive, their reputation. So a magistrate and a Scottish magistrate in a totally unrelated trial, about a week later, went off on a massive rant about the stones. Some incidents happened in Scotland. He said it's basically all the fault of people like the stones. He said they are quote, complete morons who wear their hair down to their shoulders, wear filthy clothes and act like clowns.
头版头条：“滚石，耻辱”，但这极大地提升了他们的声誉，极大地、极大地提升了他们的声誉。因此，大约一周后，一名治安法官——一名苏格兰治安法官在审理一起完全不相关的案件时，对滚石乐队进行了长篇大论的怒斥。有些事件发生在苏格兰。他说这基本上全都是像滚石这样的人的错。他说他们简直是“一群留着披肩长发、穿着肮脏衣服、行为像小丑的完完全全的白痴。”
And the news of the world came out with a wonderful verdict. They wallow in a swill tub of their own repulsiveness. Does that make you nostalgic for the good old days when you were writing for the Daily Mail? It does. Coin phrases like that. Yeah, that's exactly the kind of stuff I would come out with. Right. That's not the end of the story with the news of the world and the Rolling Stones, though, Tom.
《世界新闻报》发表了一篇精彩的判决。他们“在自己令人作呕的猪食槽里打滚”。这有没有让你对当年为《每日邮报》写作的美好旧时光产生一丝怀念？确实有。创造那样的词组。是的，这正是我会说出的那种话。对吧。不过，汤姆，这并不是《世界新闻报》与滚石乐队故事的结局。
Because next time we will be moving forward to the end of the 60s. We will talk about the great scandal of their arrest at Redlands, Keith Richards' house and their trial on drugs offenses. We'll talk about the fate of Brian Jones, who's been pushed out of his own band. And we'll come to the moment that for many people marks the very end of the sixties, the death and darkness at the Altamont Raceway. Brilliant stuff, Dominic. Thanks so much.
因为下一次我们将向前迈进，进入60年代末。我们将讨论他们在雷德兰兹（基思·理查兹的住所）被捕的惊天丑闻以及他们的毒品指控审判。我们将讨论布赖恩·琼斯的命运，他被赶出了自己的乐队。我们将迎来对许多人来说标志着六0年代真正终结的时刻——阿尔塔蒙特赛车场（Altamont Raceway）的死亡与黑暗。太精彩了，多米尼克。非常感谢。
Members of the Restless History Club can hear that right away. And if you are not a member and you would like to be and get to hear all about breaking butterflies on wheels, swimming pools and Hells Angels, then head to the restishistory.com and sign up there. We will be back on Thursday. Goodbye. Bye bye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
“不安分历史俱乐部”（Restless History Club）的成员可以立即收听。如果你还不是会员，但又想成为会员并了解所有关于在车轮上摧毁蝴蝶、游泳池和地狱天使的事情，那就前往 therestishistory.com 在那里注册吧。我们周四见。再见。拜拜。这个剧集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子即可留下评论。